THERE IS THE MORNING EVERYONE
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND CALL
TO ORDER THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE.
HEARING IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
ASSEMBLY SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
FIVE ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND SENATE COMMITTEE NUMBER.
FIVE SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE ON
CORRECTIONS PUBLIC SAFETY IS TO
JUST HURRY.
AS YOU KNOW THIS MONTH IS SEXUAL
AWARENESS AND PREVENTION
AWARENESS MONTH -- THIS MORNING
WE WILL DISCUSS THE NEED FOR
TESTING SEXUAL SALTS EVIDENCE
KIDS AS WELL AS THE FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS IDENTIFIED BY
THE STATE AUDITOR.
AUDITS -- RELATED TO SEXUAL
ASSAULT EVIDENCE GETS THE FIRST
REPORT WAS RELEASED IN OCTOBER
OF TWENTY FOURTEEN TITLED SEXUAL
ASSAULT EVIDENCE KITS.
ALTHOUGH TESTING ALL KIDS COULD
BENEFIT SEXUAL ASSAULT
INVESTIGATIONS THE EXTENT OF THE
BENEFIT IS UNKNOWN.
MORE RECENTLY IN MARCH OF THIS
YEAR THE STATE AUDITOR ISSUED A
SECOND OUT OF REPORT FOLLOW UP
SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE KITS.
TITLED.
CALIFORNIA IS NOT OBTAINED THE
CASE HOW COME INFORMATION THAT
WOULD MORE FULLY DEMONSTRATE THE
BENEFITS OF ITS RAPID DNA
SERVICE PROGRAM.
WILL ALSO DISCUSS THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE'S AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES PLANTS
IMPLEMENT CHANGES AND CORRECTIVE.
ACTIONS TO ENSURE TRACKING
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
OF ALL SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE
GETS.
I LIKE SHARE SOME STATISTICS --
FROM THE FBI AND CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION --
A SEXUAL ASSAULT OCCURS EVERY ON
AVERAGE EVERY NINETY TWO SECONDS.
A FORCIBLE RAPE OCCURS EVERY SIX
POINT TWO MINUTES.
WITHIN THE UNITED STATES NEARLY
ONE IN FIVE WOMEN.
AND ONE IN SEVENTY ONE MAN HAVE
BEEN RAPED AT SOMETIME IN THEIR
LIVES.
RATES OF VICTIMIZATION BY SEXUAL
ASSAULT VERY AMONG ETHNIC GROUPS
APPROXIMATELY ONE IN FIVE BLACK
WOMEN OR 22% ONE IN SEVEN
HISPANIC WOMEN FOURTEEN POINT 6%.
AND MORE THAN ONE IN 427% OF
WOMEN IDENTIFIED AS AMERICAN
INDIAN OR ALASKA NATIVE REPORTED
RAPE IN THEIR LIFETIMES.
WITH THE STATISTICS IN MIND I
THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF FORENSIC DNA AS A
TOOL TO HELP SOLVE AND PREVENT
CRIME AND BRING JUSTICE TO
VICTIMS.
YET FAR TOO FEW SEXUAL ASSAULT
CASES ARE RESOLVED BY THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM ONLY 50%
OF FORCIBLE RAPES ARE REPORTED
AND OF THE REPORTED RATE.
REPORTED CRIMES ONLY ABOUT ONE
QUARTER LEAD TO AN ARREST.
VAST MAJORITY OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
VICTIMS THEN DO NOT SEE THEIR
OFFENDERS BROUGHT TO JUSTICE.
IN PART BECAUSE A LARGE NUMBER
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE KIDS
REMAINED IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
CUSTODY.
AND I'M NOT BEEN SENT TO CRIED
LABS FOR ANALYSIS.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
A NUMBER OF BILLS TARGETING THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE KITS
BACKLOG.
WE ALSO APPROPRIATED SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION IN THE STATE BUDGET
TO TEST RICKETS.
TODAY HOME OPENER DISCOVER.
THE RESULTS OF OUR LEGISLATIVE
ACTIONS IN ORDER TO GAUGE THE
APPROPRIATE NEXT STEPS AND THE
BUDGET NEEDS.
THE TWO ARE REPORTS WE ARE
FOCUSED ON TODAY LOOK AT THE
PROCESSING AND ANALYSIS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE GETS BY
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
AND THEIR ASSOCIATED CRIME LABS
AS WELL AS THE REPORTING AND
TRACKING OF CASE OUTCOME
INFORMATION.
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
AND FOR PORTS RAPID DNA SERVICES.
THE OCTOBER TWENTY FOURTEEN
AUDIT FOUND.
A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT ALL OF
THE UNDER EXPLAINED.
AND WITH THAT LET ME GO TO JUST
MOVING THANK THE MEMBERS THAT
ARE HERE -- SEE IF ANYONE HAS
OPENING COMMENTS I THINK IT WAS
WEBER FOR JOINING US MR LACKEY
AND MISS RUBIO.
BILLION THIS RUBIO HAS A SELECT
COMMITTEE ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SO APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE --
THIS WEBER IS THE CHAIR OF OF A
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY AND MISTER LACKEY HAS A
EXTENSIVE BACKGROUND IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
FROM HIS PREVIOUS.
TIME.
SO WITH THAT.
AND WE LIKE TO MAKE OPENING
COMMENTS IF NOT WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND MOVE TO OUR FIRST PANEL.
MISS WEBER PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND AN MEMBERS -- I
WANT TO THANK OUR AUDITOR FOR
ONCE AGAIN PROVIDING US WITH
SOME VERY GOOD INFORMATION AND A
GOOD ANALYSIS THAT'S HERE --
IT'S SOMEWHAT DISHEARTENING --
TO SEE THE LACK OF PROGRESS
WE'VE MADE AND I THINK WE HAVE
TO VERY SERIOUSLY BEGIN TO LOOK
AT WHAT WE'RE DOING SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT IS SO.
YOU KNOW WE TALK A LOT ABOUT DNA
AND VARIOUS OTHER KINDS OF
THINGS ON TELEVISION.
AND AND YET OF OUR ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
SCIENCE AND TO MARRY IT WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS MOST ALARMING.
GIVEN THE NUMBER OF RAPES THAT
OCCUR IN THE STATE AND TO THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SOMEWHAT
POWERLESS -- WHO ARE VICTIMS OF
IT SO I'M I'M HOPING TO HEAR
MORE FROM YOU I APPRECIATE THE
DUE TO REPORTS AND?
IT ALMOST LOOKS LIKE I WAS
READING THE SAME REPORT OVER
AGAIN UNFORTUNATELY -- AT AT
SCHOOL KEEP GOING BACK AND
LOOKING AT THE DATES DOES HE
WHERE I WAS IN THE IN IN THE
PERSPECTIVE BUT I THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
AND I THINK IT CALLS ALL OF US
TO TO ACTION AND I THINK IT SOME
SERIOUS ACTION THAT WILL HAVE TO
TAKE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING.
THANK YOU.
FOR THANK YOU I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO THANK YOU FOR FOR PROVIDING
THE INFORMATION AND I KNOW THAT
YOU KNOW THAT LIKE DR WEBER SAID
IS WE TALK ABOUT SCIENCE AND HOW
VALUABLE IT IS EXCEPT.
WE'RE NOT USING IT AND I THINK --
HOPEFULLY THIS WHAT THE OUTCOME
OF THIS IS BETTER OVERSIGHT AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY THE
AUDITOR ARE FOLLOWED THROUGH BY
THE DEPARTMENT SO.
I APPRECIATE THE INFORMATION BUT
YOU'RE RIGHT DOCTOR WEBER I KEPT
LOOKING AT IT THINKING IT WAS
THE SAME APART.
AND A AND IT'S A TWO THOUSAND
AND FOURTEEN REPORT AND HERE WE
ARE IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND FIVE
YEARS LATER WE HAVEN'T REALLY
MADE ANY PROGRESS.
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH COMMITTEE ON TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DO HOLD -- THE
DEPARTMENT ACCOUNTABLE SO THAT
WE CAN -- PROCEED AND REALLY USE
THE THE THE DNA AS A TOOL TO
HELP ON SOME OF THE VICTIMS
THANK YOU.
MR LACKEY.
YOU I'VE.
SKEWS ME I WANT TO THANK THE
AUDITOR FOR HELPING US GATHER
DATA WE'VE KNOWN THIS IS BEEN A
PROBLEM EVER SINCE I'VE ELECTED
US WAS JUST INDICATED.
BUT IT'S TIME TO QUIT TALKING
ABOUT THE PROBLEM AND AND START
LOOKING AT THE SOLUTIONS AND
GOOD DATA HELPS US DO THAT.
SO THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING US
THE THE PATHWAY THAT WE NEED TO
HELP SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY VICTIMS IT
DESERVES SOME JUSTICE MAY NOW BE
ABLE TO GET SOME OF THAT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU I THINK THAT'S A GOAL
OF TODAY'S HEARING IS NOT ONLY
FINDING OUT WHAT HAPPENS IS A
TWENTY FOURTEEN BUT ALSO WITH
THE UPDATE THAT JUST WAS
RELEASED.
ABOUT A MONTH AGO I BELIEVE.
AND THE LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS WE
CAN TAKE TO HELP I DE CORRECTLY
IDENTIFY AND RESOLVE THESE
ISSUES SO WITH THAT LET'S GO TO
BEGIN WITH -- OUR FIRST PENALTY
OVERVIEW OF THE AUDIT FINDINGS
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR.
WE HAVE -- MISSILE IN HOW THE
STATE AUDITOR.
AND I BELIEVE -- MISTER BOB
HARRIS PUTS WATER AND AMANDA
MELON SENIOR AFTER THANK YOU
WHEN YOU'RE READY PLEASE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CHAIR WEBER.
MR LACKEY AND AND MISS RUBIO
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE FOR
THE RECORD MY NAME'S ELAINE HOW
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR AS AS
MANY OF YOU JUST MENTIONED WE'VE
ISSUED TWO REPORTS.
THE FIRST REPORT WAS A AN AUDIT
THAT WAS REQUESTED BY SENATOR
CORBETT -- WE SHOULD REPORT IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY FOURTEEN IN
THAT AUDIT WE WE WENT AND LOOKED
AT SOME LOCALITIES.
SACRAMENTO OAKLAND AND SAN DIEGO
TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
THERE WERE ACTUALLY UNTESTED.
A SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE KITS --
AT THOSE VARIOUS LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENTITIES AND WE FOUND CERTAINLY
THERE WERE -- AND TALK TO THEM
ABOUT SOME OF THEIR RATIONALE
WITH RESPECT TO DECISIONS THERE
WAS A LOT OF DISCRETION.
ON THE PART OF INVESTIGATORS AT
THOSE PARTICULAR ENTITIES TO
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT TO FORWARD.
THAT PARTICULAR EVIDENCE TO A
LAB TO HAVE IT TESTED MISTER
HARRIS WILL GO INTO A LITTLE BIT
MORE DETAIL ABOUT THE FIRST
AUDIT REPORT AND WHAT SOME OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS WERE.
ALSO IN THE FIRST AUDIT REPORT
WE SPENT SOME TIME AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND REALLY
LOOKED AT WHAT WE FELT WAS VERY
PROMISING PROGRAM -- AND WE
STILL BELIEVE IT'S A VERY
PROMISING PROGRAM AND CAN BE
VERY BENEFICIAL TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S THAT RAPID DNA
SERVICE PROGRAM WHERE --
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE HAS LABS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT CAN
REALLY PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
LOCAL ENTITIES TO ALLOW LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OTHER
ENTITIES TO GET THOSE KIDS
TESTED.
GET THEM TESTED RELATIVELY
QUICKLY SO THAT WE DO HAVE THE
INFORMATION AS A STATE TO EITHER
PROSECUTE AN INDIVIDUAL BUT
CERTAINLY ALSO HAVE MORE AND
MORE INFORMATION -- TO SUPPORT
THE THE NOTION THAT TESTING ALL
KIDS IS BENEFICIAL SO YOU WOULD
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT TESTING THESE KIDS
ULTIMATELY IDENTIFIED A
PERPETRATOR -- THAT PERSON WAS
CONVICTED AND PERHAPS HAS COULD
ACT COMMITTED OTHER OFFENSES SO
THIS INFORMATION IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE SO AT
THE TIME WE SHOULD THE REPORT
AND TWENTY FOURTEEN IT WAS A
PILOT PROGRAM THEY WERE WORKING
WITH ABOUT NINE COUNTIES.
WHEN WE CONDUCTED THE FOLLOW UP?
AND WE WAITED A FEW YEARS TO
GIVE THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
THE OPPORTUNITY -- TO IMPLEMENT
SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
MISTER HARRIS WILL TALK ABOUT
THAT A LITTLE BIT BUT WHEN WE
WENT BACK OUT IN IN -- LATE LAST
YEAR -- AN ISSUE THE REPORT IN
MARCH OF THIS YEAR THEY
CERTAINLY HAVE EXPANDED THE
PROGRAM TO MORE COUNTIES BUT WE
STILL AREN'T SEEING THOSE
ENTITIES REPORTING INFORMATION
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SO
THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE HAS.
INFORMATION STATEWIDE ABOUT THE
BENEFITS -- AND SOME OF THE
OUTCOMES RELATED TO DECISIONS --
AND TESTING THESE PARTICULAR
KIDS SO I CERTAINLY A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I'M GONNA HAND OVER
TO MISTER HARRIS HE'LL TALK
ABOUT THE FIRST REPORT.
AND THEN MS MELON WAS THE
SUPERVISOR ON THE SECOND REPORT
WORKING WITH MISTER HARRIS SO
SHE WILL GET INTO MORE SPECIFICS
ON THE FOLLOW UP WAS REALLY
FOCUSED ON THAT THAT RADS
PROGRAM THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ADMINISTERS SO WITH THAT
MISTER CHAIR I'LL I'LL HANDED
OVER MISTER HARRIS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IS MY
NAME IS BOB HERE SOME OUT OF
PRINCIPLE WITH THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE AND AS THE
STATE AUDITOR INDICATED -- I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED IN BOTH OF OUR
AUDITS BUT THE TWENTY FOURTEEN
AUDIT AND THE FOLLOW UP ON IT
THAT WE RELEASED EARLIER THIS
YEAR -- I'M GOING TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND
INFORMATION ABOUT THOSE AUDITS --
AND OUR REVIEW OF LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES BUT ALSO
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE -- AND
SOME OF THE KEY FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
ORIGINAL OUGHTA AND SOME OF THE
INFORMATION GATHERING EFFORTS
THAT HAVE HAPPENED SINCE THEN MS
MELLON MORE THAN COVER OUR
FOLLOW UP ON IT.
AND THE RELATED RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT CAME OUT OF THAT AUDIT.
NOW I'M REALLY OUR MAIN FINDINGS
AND CONCLUSIONS FROM THE
ORIGINAL ON IT -- AT THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL RELATED TO A
LACK OF INFORMATION ABOUT SEXUAL
ASSAULT EVIDENCE KITS WE REALLY
FOUND THAT THERE WAS -- NO
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW MANY OF
THOSE KIDS EXISTED IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HOW MANY OF THEM
WERE BEING SUBMITTED FOR
ANALYSIS AND WHAT HAPPENS AS A
RESULT OF THAT ANALYSIS -- THOSE
WERE THE KEY AREAS WHERE WE MADE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THERE BE
MORE INFORMATION GATHERING.
BY WAY OF BACKGROUND THOUGH A
SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE KID IS
THE BY PRODUCT OF A VICTIM WHO
REPORTS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT THE
SIDING TO UNDERGO AN INVASIVE
MEDICAL EXAMINATION.
DURING THAT EXAM A TRAINED
MEDICAL EXAMINER WILL ATTEMPT TO
COLLECT EVIDENCE FROM THE
VICTIM'S BODY THAT HOPEFULLY
WILL CONTAIN A DNA PROFILE
RELATED TO THE SUSPECT IN THE
INVESTIGATION.
THAT COULD BE POTENTIALLY VERY
VALUABLE TO THE INVESTIGATORS
AND THE PROSECUTORS OF IN THAT
CASE BUT IT'S ONLY ACCESSIBLE TO
THEM IF THEY THEN SUBMIT THAT
KIT TO A CRIME LAB FOR ANALYSIS --
CRIME LABS WHEN THEY ANALYZE A
SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE KIT
THEY'RE ATTEMPTING TO ATTAIN
THAT DNA PROFILE FOR FOR A
SUSPECT IN THE INVESTIGATION AND
IF THEY'RE SUCCESSFUL IN DOING
THAT THEY CAN UPLOAD THE PROFILE
TO WHAT IS KNOWN AS CODIS WHICH
IS THE COMBINED DNA INDEX SYSTEM.
CURTIS IS A NETWORK OF DATABASES
THAT STRETCHES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THE CONTAINS DENY
PROFILES FOR MULTIPLE MANY MANY
INDIVIDUALS.
AND THE HOPE IS THAT WHEN YOU
UPLOAD A DNA PROFILE FROM AN
EVIDENCE KIT INTO CODIS.
BUT IT WILL THEN MATCH AGAINST
ANOTHER PROFILE THAT'S ALREADY
IN THE SYSTEM AND COULD
POTENTIALLY PROVIDE YOU THE NAME
OF THE SUSPECT -- IN ONE
PARTICULAR CASE WE REVIEWED
DURING THE FOLLOW ABOUT IT WE
WERE ABLE TO IDENTIFY THAT LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT TOOK.
THE STATEMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED TO THEM BY THE VICTIM
COMBINED WITH A HIT WHICH IS
WHAT THAT MATCHES CALLED FROM
THE CODIS SYSTEM THAT NAME TO
THE SUSPECT.
AND IN COMBINATION THOSE TWO
PIECES OF EVIDENCE WERE CRITICAL
TO THEM ARRESTING THE SUSPECT
AND FORWARDING THE CASE TO THE
PROSECUTOR FOR PROSECUTION.
SO IT'S REALLY VALUABLE EVIDENCE
I'M IN INFORMATION THAT
INVESTIGATORS COULD HAVE ACCESS
TO BUT DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
UNLESS THEY MAKE THAT SUBMITTAL
TO A CRIME LAB.
IN OUR ORIGINAL AUDIT REPORT WE
REVIEWED THREE AGENCIES AS THE
STATE AUDITOR INDICATED.
NOT ALL OF THE SEXUAL ASSAULT
EVIDENCE KITS AT THOSE AGENCIES
HAD BEEN SUBMITTED TO THEIR
RESPECTIVE CRIME LABS.
IT WAS RIGHT AROUND 50% OF THE
TIME WE CONDUCTED THE ORIGINAL
AUDIT THAT'S WHAT OUR REVIEW
SHOWED ABOUT 50% HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED AND ABOUT 50% HAD NOT
BEEN SUBMITTED.
AND THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
INVESTIGATORS ARE PROVIDED AS A
VARIETY OF REASONS FOR WHY THEY
DIDN'T FOR THE THE EVIDENCE GETS
TO THE CRIME LABS FOR ANALYSIS.
BUT AS I SAID BEFORE STATEWIDE
THERE'S NO DATA OR THERE WAS NO
DATA THEN AND THERE IS NO DATA
NOW.
ON HOW MANY OF THOSE KIDS EXISTS
STATEWIDE.
HOW MANY OF THEM HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED AND AND A KEY PIECE OF
INFORMATION IS WHAT ARE THE
REASONS WHY KIDS ARE NOT BEING
SUBMITTED TO CRIME LABS AS I
MENTIONED THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WE VISITED GAVE US
REASONS SUCH AS?
HAVING BEEN ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY
ARREST A SUSPECT WITHOUT THE KID
AN ANALYSIS OR HAVING DETERMINED
THAT -- THE ISSUE WAS ONE OF
CONSENT WHICH IS AN ISSUE THEY
FEEL LIKE IT'S NOT RESOLVABLE
THROUGH DNA EVIDENCE.
BUT REGARDLESS WE DON'T HAVE
STATEWIDE DATA ON WHETHER THOSE
OF THE REASONS STATEWIDE FOR WHY
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE
MAKING THOSE DECISIONS.
SO KEY RECOMMENDATION FROM OUR
ORIGINAL AUDIT REPORT WAS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRE THE
REPORTING OF THAT INFORMATION
THOSE THREE KEY DATA POINTS.
HOW MANY KIDS EXIST HOW MANY OF
BEEN SUBMITTED AND NOT SUBMITTED
FOR TESTING?
AND THEN THE REASONS WHY KIDS
WERE NOT TURNED IN FOR TESTING --
THE LEGISLATURE ADOPTED THAT
RECOMMENDATION THAT IS NOW STATE
LAW AND THE FIRST REPORT ON THE
OF LOCALS TO JUSTICE.
AND THAT JUSTICE IS REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE IS DUE SOMETIME
SOON SO HOPEFULLY WE'LL BE ABLE
TO ACCESS THAT -- IMPORTANT AND
VITAL -- INFORMATION ABOUT
SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE GETS
SOON IN TERMS OF HOW MANY EXIST.
REAL QUICKLY THOUGH BEFORE I
TURN IT OVER TO MISS MEL IN OUR
SECOND KEY RECOMMENDATION WAS
RELATED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S RADS PROGRAM.
THAT PROGRAM IS UNIQUE IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE IT IS THE
STATE'S FUND THE STATE FUNDED
PROGRAM TO TEST ALL SEXUAL
ASSAULT EVIDENCE KITS.
AND THAT PROGRAM THE KIDS GO
FROM THE MEDICAL EXAMINER
STRAIGHT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE CRIME LAB THEY DON'T
PASSED THROUGH THE INVESTIGATOR
SO THAT THE INVESTIGATOR DECIDES
WHETHER TO FOUR DIFFERENT
ALICE'S OR NOT.
THAT KEY DIFFERENCE MAYES THE
MADE THE PROGRAM UNIQUE IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND THEN STILL
MAKES IT UNIQUE TODAY AS THE
STATE'S FUNDING THAT PROGRAM.
AND WE SAW THAT AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COLLECT
INFORMATION THAT GOES BEYOND
JUST WHETHER THE KITS WERE
TESTED OR NOT BUT ALSO WHAT
HAPPENS AFTERWARDS WHAT KIND OF
POSITIVE CASE OUTCOME
INFORMATION COULD WE LEARN ABOUT
THOSE CASES WERE SUSPECTS
ARRESTED AS A RESULT OF THAT
ANALYSIS.
WERE THEY CONVICTED AS A RESULT
OF THAT ANALYSIS.
SO WE RECOMMENDED THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE COLLECT
THAT INFORMATION FROM ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES THAT
PARTICIPATE IN ITS RATS PROGRAM.
AND THEN REPORT THAT INFORMATION
TO THE LEGISLATURE AGAIN
INCREASING THE AVAILABLE
STATEWIDE INFORMATION ABOUT
THESE KIDS.
NOW IN THE YEARS SINCE WE'VE
DONE OUR ORIGINAL AUDIT THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE HAS AT LEAST
AMENDED ITS AGREEMENTS WITH THE
AGENCIES THAT PARTICIPATE IN THE
RATS PROGRAM. TO ASK THEM TO
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION BUT FOR
A FEW YEARS NOW WE HAVEN'T SEEN
JUSTICE ACTUALLY PROVIDE THAT
CASE OUTCOME INFORMATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THAT'S WHAT
PROMPTED OUR FOLLOW UP EFFORT.
AND THAT'S THE EFFORT THAT MISS
MELONS GOING TO DESCRIBE YOU
KNOW.
THANK YOU MORNING HI MY NAME IS
AMANDA MILLEN AND AGAIN I WAS
THE AUDIT SUPERVISOR ON THE
FOLLOW UP ON IT.
SO DURING OUR FOLLOW UP WE FOUND
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
HAD VERY LITTLE INFORMATION ON
CASE OUTCOMES ASSOCIATED WITH
THE HITS THAT IT PROVIDED.
IT HAD NO INFORMATION WHATSOEVER
ABOUT 67% OF THOSE CASES MEANING
IT DIDN'T KNOW WHETHER SOMEONE
HAD BEEN CONVICTED WHETHER
SOMEONE HAD BEEN ARRESTED OR
EVEN WHETHER INVESTIGATORS HAD
EVEN INVESTIGATED THOSE HITS.
AND AS A RESULT IN HAVE THAT
INFORMATION TO PROVIDE TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND WE FOUND THAT THE REASON
THAT IT DIDN'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION IS THAT IT HAD MADE
A LACKLUSTER EFFORT TO OBTAIN
THAT INFORMATION.
WE FOUND THAT IT HADN'T EVEN
TOLD MOST RATS PARTICIPANTS THAT
THEY SHOULD PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION.
IT HADN'T TRAIN MOST READ
PARTICIPANTS ON HOW TO REPORT
THAT INFORMATION AND HADN'T
PROVIDED GUIDANCE ON HOW TO
REPORT THAT.
AND WE FOUND IN THE LIMITED DATA
THAT JUSTICE DID HAVE
INACCURACIES AN OUTDATED
INFORMATION AS A RESULT OF THAT.
AS A RESULT OF ALL OF THIS
JUSTICE MISS A VERY REAL
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE VALUABLE
INFORMATION.
THAT COULD BE HELPFUL IN THE
EFFORT TO FURTHER SEXUAL ASSAULT
INVESTIGATIONS.
MORE THAN THAT WE FOUND THAT
CASE OUTCOME INFORMATION WOULD
BE A VERY HELPFUL TOOL.
IN THE EFFORT TO IMPROVE SEXUAL
ASSAULT CASE INVESTIGATIONS EVEN
IF THE LEGISLATURE DOES MANDATE
THAT ALL SEXUAL ASSAULT KIT
SHOULD BE TESTED.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE CASE OUTCOME
INFORMATION COULD SHOW US WHAT
BARRIERS ARE OUT THERE THAT ARE
PREVENTING SEXUAL ASSAULT
INVESTIGATIONS FROM HAPPENING.
RECENT RESEARCH INTO THE REASONS
WHY SEXUAL ASSAULT KITS ARE NOT
TESTED WHEN THEY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN TESTED.
HAVE FOUND A NUMBER OF PROBLEMS
THEY FOUND THAT THERE ARE
IMPLICIT BIASES AND SOME LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS THAT
PREDISPOSE THEM TO NOT BELIEVING
A VICTIM OR TO ADD BELIEVE THAT
THEY ARE NOT WILLING TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROCESS -- IT
IS ALSO SHOWN THAT THERE'S JUST
A LACK OF INVESTIGATIVE
RESOURCES AT A LOT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
INVESTIGATE CASES.
INCLUDING SEXUAL ASSAULT CASES
THOSE BARRIERS DO NOT GO AWAY
WHEN THE KID IS TESTED.
THOSE BARRIERS CAN AND DO STILL
PREVENT SEXUAL ASSAULT CASES
FROM BEING INVESTIGATED AND
PROSECUTED EVEN AFTER THERE IS A
HIT -- SO FOR EXAMPLE.
THE UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE RECENTLY ISSUED SEVERAL
GRANTS TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE NATION.
TO ADDRESS ON TESTING KITS THREE
CITIES RECEIVED GRANTS. TO
ADDRESS NOT UNTESTED KITS BUT TO
ADDRESS HITS THAT THEY GOT FROM
TESTED KIDS BECAUSE THEY NOW HAD
A BACKLOG OF HITS RATHER THAN
KIDS ONE OF THOSE CITIES IS
FRESNO CALIFORNIA.
FRESNO HAS SEVEN HUNDRED HITS
SITTING ON ITS SHELVES GOING ON
INVESTIGATED BECAUSE BEFORE THEY
GOT THE GRANT THEY DID NOT HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO INVESTIGATE
THOSE HITS.
AND THAT CAN HAVE DEVASTATING
REPERCUSSIONS WELL WE HEARD
RECENTLY ABOUT A CASE OUT OF
NORTH CAROLINA WERE A LITTLE
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD GIRL WAS RAPED
AND MURDERED AND HER BODY WAS
DITCH ON THE SIDE OF THE ROAD.
AND THEY FOUND OUT THAT THE
PERSON THAT THEY ARRESTED AND
CHARGED WITH THAT CRIME HAD TWO
YEARS EARLIER.
AT COMMITTED AN ADDITIONAL RAPE
WHERE THEY HAD A HIT.
OUT OF THE SEXUAL ASSAULT KIT
COMING FROM THAT RAPE AND THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN NORTH
CAROLINA SAID IF THEY HAD
FOLLOWED UP ON THAT HIT THAT
LITTLE GIRL WOULD PROBABLY STILL
BE ALIVE TODAY.
THAT CAN NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
BUT CALIFORNIA DOES NOT HAVE THE
INFORMATION OR THE TOOLS RIGHT
NOW TO IDENTIFY WHERE WE'RE AT
RISK OF SOMETHING LIKE THAT
HAPPENING WE WOULD NOT KNOW
ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING ON IT
FRESNO IF NOT FOR THAT GRANT
PROGRAM IF WE HADN'T GONE DOWN
THERE AND TALK TO THEM.
BUT CASE OUTCOME INFORMATION CAN
PROVIDE THAT TOOL. TO ALLOW US
TO IDENTIFY THOSE ISSUES IT
WOULD SHOW US WHERE WE HAVE.
A BUNCH OF HITS THAT HAVE GONE
ON INVESTIGATED IT WAS SHOW US
WHERE THERE HAS BEEN AN
INVESTIGATION BUT THERE'S BEEN
NO ARRESTS MADE.
IT WOULD SHOW US WHERE LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS SUBMITTED A
BUNCH OF CASES THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY BUT THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY HAS NOT FILED ANY
CHARGES.
YOU WOULD BE A POWERFUL TOOL IN
PROVIDING A LOT OF INFORMATION
THAT WE COULD USE TO IDENTIFY
AND REMOVE THE UNDERLYING
BARRIERS THAT PREVENT SEXUAL
ASSAULT CASES FOR BEING.
EFFECTIVELY INVESTIGATED AND
PROSECUTED AND FOR THAT REASON
WE'RE RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IF IT DOES REQUIRE
THAT ALL SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE
KITS IN THE STATE BE TESTED.
THAT INCLUDE A REQUIREMENT THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES REPORT
CASE OUTCOME INFORMATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THAT
ALREADY COLLECTS INFORMATION ON
SEXUAL ASSAULT CASES.
AND THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE PUBLISHED SUMMARY
INFORMATION -- ON THAT DATA.
SO THAT'S THIS THAT'S OUR
FINDINGS BUT IF YOU GUYS HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS WE HAVE ANSWERED
THEM.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY AND YOU
KNOW.
THE WAY IT'S FRAME I THINK --
JUST READING THE FACIAL
EXPRESSIONS OF MY COLLEAGUES
HERE -- YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
WONDERING.
WELL MAYBE THIS WEBER AND
SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE CAN FIND OUT WHERE THE SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION THAT WE
ALLOCATED PREVIOUSLY -- HAS GONE
IN.
HI THIS BE UTILIZED.
SINCE ARE STILL BEING OUT THERE
SO QUESTIONS BUT LET ME JUST.
ASK SO TALL CASE INFORMATION.
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT FOR THE
FOR THE OUTCOMES AND THE
METHODOLOGIES THAT YOU LOOKED AT
BETWEEN THE DIFFERENT -- LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENTS IS AGENCIES
WAS IS CONSISTENT ACROSS ALL OF
THEM OR THEY ALL KIND OF
DIFFERENT -- YEP STRIVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW SYSTEMIC THIS IS.
GIVEN THAT WE DIDN'T -- GO
THROUGH EVERY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY TO ACTUALLY SEE WHICH
ONES FOLLOW THROUGH WITH THE
KIDS WHICH ONES DID NOT AND
REASONS WHY.
THEY GOT MISTERS TALKED ABOUT
MAYBE SOME -- OR MAYBE IT WAS
YOU.
MISSPELLING ABOUT THE IMPLICIT
BIASES AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
SO WE DIDN'T LOOK INTO THE
POTENTIAL THAT THERE WERE ANY
IMPLICIT BIASES AT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WE VISITED
THAT WAS A LITTLE BIT OUTSIDE
THE SCOPE OF WHAT WE WERE DOING
THERE.
WE REALLY WENT THERE TO SEE WHAT
INFORMATION WAS AVAILABLE ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT JUSTICE IT SAID
THAT THERE MIGHT NOT BE CASE
OUTCOME INFORMATION BEING
REPORTED.
WAS BECAUSE THOSE CASES HADN'T
PROGRESSED FAR ENOUGH ALONG FOR
THERE TO EVEN BE CASE OUTCOME
INFORMATION.
AND SO THAT'S WHY WE WENT DOWN
TO THE THREE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES IS TO FIND OUT IS THAT
TRUE DO THEY REALLY HAVE A
REALLY NOT GOT ANY CASE THAT
COMES TO PROVIDE.
AND WE FOUND THAT THAT WASN'T
TRUE MOST OF THE TIME ALMOST ALL
OF THE CASES THEY HAD SOME CASE
OUTCOME INFORMATION.
SO THAT'S WHY WE WENT DOWN THERE
WE DIDN'T EVALUATE THE
REASONABLENESS OF THEIR
DECISIONS TO HALT AN
INVESTIGATION OR TO PUSH AN
INVESTIGATION FORWARD.
WHILE WE WERE THERE AND PLACE
FOR THEM THE INPUT THAT
INFORMATION WOULD THAT BE INTO
THE RATS PROGRAM.
YES YES SO THE DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE IS TO ESTABLISH A
DATABASE CALLED THE CHOP
DATABASE -- THAT'S WHERE THEY
HAVE ASKED LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO REPORT THE CASE COME
INFORMATION -- AS MISSPELLING
COVERED THOUGH EARLIER WE FOUND
THERE'S REALLY A LACK OF
INFORMATION IN THAT DATABASE AND
EVEN WHAT'S THERE IS -- NOT
ALWAYS ACCURATE.
OKAY YES MY COLLEAGUES IF THEY
HAVE ANY.
QUESTIONS.
THIS WEBER PLACE CLEARLY -- I
REMEMBER THE LEGISLATION THAT
REQUIRED US TO HAVE ALL KIDS
TESTED YOU KNOW AND I I I I FEEL
LIKE I'M.
DEAL WITH MY CHILDREN WHEN YOU
TELL THEM TO DO ONE THING AND
THEY DO THAT ONE THING.
AND IN THE PROCESS SO WOULD TIM
THINGS SHOULD BE DONE BEFORE
THAT BUT THEY JUST DID THE ONE
THAT I TOLD THEM.
AND YOU JUST AS SOON WHEN YOU
KNOW WHAT WORD ALSO MEANS A SO --
IT IS IT IS AMAZING THAT WE ARE.
AT THIS POINT AFTER THESE YEARS
AT THAT THE LAST FIVE YEARS THAT
TO WHERE WE WERE OUTRAGED ABOUT
THE KIDS NOT BEING TESTED.
BUT NOW WE'RE GETTING THEM
TESTED BUT THAT WILL NOT
FOLLOWING THROUGH WITH MUCH ELSE
OTHER THAN THAT.
OF ESPECIALLY IF WE THINK ABOUT
AND NOT ONLY FINDING THE
PERPETRATORS WHO DONE SOME
CRIMES BUT POSSIBLY EVEN HAVING
PEOPLE THAT WE'VE CONVICTED.
THAT SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED IN A LAB THE HORROR OF
THAT ALONE IS A PERSON BEING
ACCUSED OF SOMETHING AND HAVING
THEIR LIVES COMPLETELY DISRUPTED.
FOR FOR YEARS ONLY TO DISCOVER
THAT THERE'S DNA THAT COULD HAVE
SAID THIS PERSON DID NOT DO IT.
THAT IS MOST ALARMING TO ME --
AND SO I'D -- I THINK WE'VE
TAKEN THE CHARGE MY STAFF IS
HERE -- WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
OBVIOUSLY DO SOMETHING IN THE
BUDGET WITH THE MONEY THAT WE'VE
GIVEN THEM PUT SOME STIPULATIONS
ON IT.
WITH REGARDS TO REPORTING AND
AND GETTING INFORMATION BACK TO
US BUT IT'S JUST UNFORTUNATE
THAT WE HAVE ALL OF THESE THINGS
AVAILABLE AND WE DON'T HAVE SEEN
THE ENERGY OR THE DESIRE AS YOU
POINTED OUT.
THE LACK OF THE LACK LUSTER
METHOD IN WHICH WE JUST KINDA OF
TAKE THE INFORMATION AND NOT
FOLLOW THROUGH WITH IT WHEN WE
HAVE THE POTENTIAL. TO DO AN
AWFUL LOT OF THINGS AND TO
PREVENT SOME CRIMES TO AS WELL
SO I I IT IS VERY ALARMING --
GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF MONEY WE PUT
INTO THIS PROJECT TO TO GET
THESE KIDS TESTED TO DISCOVER
THAT.
THERE'S VERY LITTLE HAPPENING
WITH ME AFTERWARDS VERY ALARMING
BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
THOROUGHNESS.
YEAH.
GIVE SOMEONE NUMBER LACKEY.
THE MOST ALARMING THING TO ME IS
NOT THE MONEY SPENT BUT IT'S
IT'S THE THE IMPACT ON PEOPLE'S
LIVES I MEAN AS YOU TALK.
ABOUT THE TRAGEDY WITH THAT
YOUNG LADY THE VERY NATURE OF
THIS CRIME IS THAT IT.
THE PERPETUATES.
I CONTINUES AND SO THAT'S THE
URGENCY THAT ALL AGENCIES
INVOLVED SHOULD BE.
ENGAGED IN AT AND THEY SHOULD.
CERTAINLY HAVE A GRASP ON I
DON'T.
HAVE ANY UNDERSTANDING HOW THIS
COULD BE SO DRASTICALLY --
ALARMING IT REALLY IS.
THIS IS A HUGE PRIORITY IN MY
MIND THAT THAT SHOULD BE
FOLLOWED UP ON AND THE
COORDINATION IS WHERE THE
PROBLEM IS.
I MEAN YOU HAVE PEOPLE DOING
WHAT THEY THINK THEY'RE REQUIRED
TO DO.
AND BEYOND THAT THERE DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE MUCH COORDINATION
GOING INVOLVED -- THEY'RE JUST
ASSUMING AND THERE'S A LOT OF
ASSUMPTION AS INDICATED THAT'S A
TERRIBLE THING TO DO -- I JUST
HOPE THAT WE ACT NOW NOW THAT WE
HAVE THIS DADDO WE WE NEED IT'S
UP TO US TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
OVERSEE BECAUSE THAT'S ONE OF
OUR JOBS IS TO OVERSEE AND MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE.
DOING WHAT IS EXPECTED AND
FORTUNE UNFORTUNATELY I THINK
THERE'S A BIG GAP AND WHAT'S
BEING ACCOMPLISHED WHAT SHOULD
BE ACCOMPLISHED AS IT.
RELATES THIS IS EVIDENCE THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT THIS IS EVIDENCE --
IT'S NOT JUST.
NEBULOUS INFORMATION THIS IS
VERY VERY TARGETED.
AND SO WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO REALLY USE THAT INFORMATION.
TO MAKE GOOD OUTCOMES AND TO
PREVENT TRAGEDY THAT'S THE HOPE
IS PREVENTION NOT NECESSARILY
JUST.
MEETING OUT PUNISHMENT BUT
PREVENTING MORE VICTIMS THAT'S
WHAT I HOPE.
WE CAN ACCOMPLISH BY USING THIS
DATA BECAUSE STATUS WHAT'S MOST
POWERFUL AND I THINK THAT'S OUR
DUTY. NINE THANK YOU MISTER
LACKEY IN A NOTE THE
LEGISLATURE'S PASS LEGISLATION
PASSED TO FIRST ASCERTAIN HOW
MANY.
KIDS WENT UNTESTED.
AND THEN THERE WAS LEGISLATION
LAST YEAR THE GOVERNOR VETOED
AND OTHERS CURRENT LEGISLATION --
PLEA BY WE'RE ALSO JOINED BY
SENATOR DRAWS A BUT BY SENATOR
LEYVA.
OVER THE SENATE SB TWENTY TO
HELP ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
ISSUES AS WELL BUT WE WILL
DEFINITELY AS A COMMITTEE START
LOOKING INTO.
HOW THE REST OF TESTIMONY GOES
WITH THE REST OF THE PANELS?
A LOOK AT POSSIBLE LEGISLATION
THE CASE HOW COME INFORMATION.
AND PROP SO WE COULD MOVE
FORWARD IN THAT DIRECTION.
BUT WITH THAT -- LET ME ASK
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS --
HEARING AND SEEING THAT AND
LET'S GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO OUR
SECOND PANEL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
REMOVED OUR SECOND PANEL.
IT'S COMMENTS AND RESPONSES ON
THE AUDIT FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WITH US TODAY WE HAVE
VERY MILLER DIRECTOR OF THE
BUREAU OF FORENSIC SERVICES OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE --
CHRIS RYAN CHIEF DIVISION OF
OPERATIONS DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
NANCY O'MALLEY DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
FOR THE ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE MORGAN GEYER
SUPERVISING -- DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FOR THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE THANK YOU GUYS FOR
JOINING US THIS MORNING.
AND PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE
READY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN SALAS AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE -- MY NAME IS VERY
MILLER AND ON BEHALF OF ATTORNEY
GENERAL THE SERRA THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY -- AS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S BUREAU OF FORENSIC
SERVICES.
I'M HERE TODAY TO DISCUSS THE
EFFORTS THE DEPARTMENT IS MADE
TO STREAMLINE THE ANALYSIS AND
COMBINED DNA INDEX SYSTEM HIT
NOTIFICATION PROCESS.
AS WELL AS THE DEPARTMENT'S
RAPID DNA SERVICE COMMONLY
REFERRED TO AS THE RATS PROGRAM
WHICH YOU JUST HEARD ABOUT.
THE TWENTY FOURTEEN AUDIT AND
THE TWENTY NINETEEN FOLLOW UP ON
A REPORTS RELATED TO SEXUAL
ASSAULT EVIDENCE.
AS MOST OF YOUR LIKELY AWARE IN
TWO THOUSAND FOUR VOTERS PASSED
PROPOSITION SIXTY NINE WHICH
EXPANDED MODIFIED PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION -- PERTAINING TO THE
CAL DNA DATA BANK AND AS A
RESULT SEARCHES MADE AGAINST
THAT RAPIDLY GROWING DATABASE
BEGAN TO GENERATE SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE DNA COLD HITS.
AND A COLD IT OCCURS WHEN THE
CODE A SEARCH OF AN EVIDENCE
PROFILE FROM A CASE WITHOUT A
SUSPECT RESULTS IN A MATCH TO AN
OFFENDER WHOSE IN THE DATABASE.
CODICE IS THE F. B. I.'S DNA
DATABASE THAT INCLUDES LOCAL
STATE AND NATIONAL INDEXES AND
IS USED WHEN AN UNKNOWN DNA
PROFILES OBTAINED FROM EVIDENCE.
BASED ON THE INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF COLD HITS AND THE
NECESSITY FOR US TO PROVIDE A
REPORT FOR EVERY HIT TO THE
INVESTIGATING AGENCY.
A DATABASE WAS DEVELOPED TO AID
IN THE REPORTING OF HITS AND
FOLLOW THE PROGRESS OF THE
FENDER HITS IN CASE TO CASE
MATCHES.
THIS DATABASE PROJECT WAS
ENTITLED THE COLD HIT OUTCOME
PROJECT OR CHOP AND WAS DEPLOYED
SEPTEMBER FIFTEENTH.
TWO THOUSAND NINE CHOP WAS
INITIALLY PROVIDED TO A LIMITED
NUMBER OF AGENCIES AND BY JULY
TWENTY TEN WAS DEPLOYED IN TEN
COUNTIES WITH APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY SUBSCRIBERS.
TODAY CHOP NOW KNOWN AS THE
CODIS HIT OUTCOME PROJECT IS
USED IN SOME CAPACITY BY ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
AND HAS APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN
HUNDRED USERS.
CHAVEZ SEVERAL BENEFITS THAT
HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED BY DOJ AT
NO COST TO LOCAL AGENCIES.
IT MAKES THE HIT NOTIFICATION
DOCUMENT THAT WE PROVIDE TO
THOSE AGENCIES A PORTABLE
DOCUMENT FORMAT PDF THAT THEY
CAN THEY CAN GO IN AND GET.
IT SENDS AUTOMATED EMAIL ALERTS
WHEN THEIR HITS BETWEEN OFFENDER
HIT PROFILES IN FRANCE A GUN ON
RECORDS.
IT SENDS AUTOMATED EMAIL ALERTS
OF CASE TO CASE HITS WHEN A DNA
MATCH OCCURS BETWEEN EVIDENCE
PROFILES FROM DIFFERENT CASES.
IT SERVES AS AN AUTOMATED SYSTEM
FOR TRACKING THE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA FORENSIC DNA RECORDS
THAT HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED TO
CODICE.
IT SENDS AUTOMATED EMAIL ALERTS
ON ESTABLISHMENTS MARK
ANNIVERSARIES THREE SIX TEN
YEARS TO ASSIST DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS OFFICES WITH FILING A
JOHN DOE WARRANTS.
IN IT ALSO SERVES AS THE BASIS
FOR TO STATISTICS AND REPORTING
FOR PARTICIPATING AGENCIES.
THESE UPDATES TO CHOP ALLOW FOR
MORE EFFICIENT NOTIFICATION
PROCESS AND IMPROVE CODIS HIT --
TRACKING AND COMMUNICATION.
THE RAPID DNA SERVICE STARTED AS
A PILOT PROGRAM IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN TO BETTER SERVE VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
IN AN ATTEMPT TO ENSURE TIMELY
IN A PARTIAL PROCESSING OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT CASES THE RATS
PROGRAM WAS CREATED TO RAPIDLY
RECEIVE AN ANALYZE THE MOST
PROBATIVE SAMPLES IN SEXUAL
ASSAULT CASES.
IT WAS A NOVEL APPROACH AS IT
ALLOWED THE MEDICAL STAFF TO
SUBMIT THE EVIDENCE DIRECTLY TO
THE LABORATORY WITHOUT FIRST
PASSING THROUGH THE HANDS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THE APPROACH NOT ONLY LEAD TO AN
INCREASE IN THE EFFICIENCY OF
EVIDENCE PROCESSING BUT ALSO
DEMONSTRATED -- RELATIVELY THE
SAME WHAT WE WOULD CALL HIT RATE.
AS A TRADITIONAL SEXUAL ASSAULT
EVIDENCE ANALYSIS FULL KIT
ANALYSIS SO WE SAW GOOD
STATISTICS EITHER WAY. TO TRY TO
DETERMINE THE EXTENT OF THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE BACKLOG
PROBLEM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR PERFORMED AN AUDIT IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN WHICH YOU JUST
HEARD ABOUT PRIOR TO US COMING
UP HERE -- ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WAS THAT DOJ
REQUIRE ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES IN THE RED SERVICE
AREAS WHICH WERE SEVEN COUNTIES
AT THE TIME PLUS -- ON A LIMITED
TERM ALAMEDA COUNTY -- AS PART
OF OUR PROCESS TO HELP THEM GET
STARTED AS WELL TO ENTER AN
UPDATE INFORMATION INTO CHOPS
THAT OUTCOME INFORMATION WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR BETTER
CONVERSATION STATISTICS AND
DECISION MAKING.
AND AT THE TIME BFS AGREED TO
MODIFY THE MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAD
DEVELOPED FOR THESE COUNTIES TO
CLEARLY OUTLINE THE EXPECTATION
THAT PARTICIPANTS USE AN UPDATE
CHOP.
SOME OF THE USER MODIFIED WITH
THE CORRECT LANGUAGE NOT ALL
WERE MODIFIED DUE TO THE RAPID
EXPANSION THAT OCCURRED BETWEEN
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE PROGRAM EXPANDED TO
THIRTY NINE COUNTIES.
OUT OF THE FORTY SIX COUNTIES
THAT WE SERVE.
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES THAT DO NOT
HAVE THEIR OWN -- SORRY THAT
DON'T HAVE THEIR OWN LABS THOSE
ARE THE AREAS WE SERVE THEY
DON'T HAVE THEIR OWN LAPS.
SEVERAL USE WERE NOT CREATED OR
SIGN FOR NEW COUNTIES ENTERED
THE PROGRAM -- WELL SOME OF THIS
MAY HAVE BEEN IMPROVED OF BETTER
RESOURCES TO MAINTAIN THE
NECESSARY OUT REACHING
COMMUNICATION FOR THIS NON
MANDATED PROGRAM IT IS APPARENT
THAT WITHOUT A CLEAR LEGISLATIVE
MANDATE IN PLACE.
BFS WILL BE VERY POORLY POSITION
TO GET A 100% OF THE AMMO YOU
SIGNED TO PROPERLY ENFORCE.
OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS SINCE
THE FIRST CALIFORNIA STATE ON A
REPORT WAS ISSUED.
BFS IS EXPERIENCED SOME VERY
CRITICAL DEFINITE DEFICITS IN
OUR PRIMARY REVENUE FUND AND
THAT'S THE THE ANY ID FUND THE
FUND DECREASED BY 12%.
BETWEEN.
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN AND FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN AND IT WAS DOWN 27% BY
THE END OF FISCAL YEAR.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AS A RESULT
OF YOUR WAS ALSO FORCED TO
RELEASE A NUMBER OF VACANCIES
THAT WE COULDN'T SUSTAIN.
THE VARIOUS REVIEWS OF THE
PROGRAM WERE CONDUCTED BY
PREVIOUS MANAGEMENT PRIOR TO THE
FOLLOW UP OUT OF THERE WAS A
HIGH TURNOVER OF STAFF AND
LEADERSHIP.
AND WHILE THE SCIENTIFIC
ANALYSIS AND REPORTING SIDE OF
THIS PROGRAM IS STILL VERY
SUCCESSFUL.
THE NON MANDATED CHOP OUTCOME
REPORTING WAS UNDENIABLY NEED
IMPROVEMENTS INCLUDING A
LEGISLATIVE REQUIREMENT TO
REPORT OUTCOMES IN CHOP.
INITIAL OUT REACH. FOR THE RATS
PROGRAM WAS VERY ACTIVE AS WE
WERE ONLY DEALING WITH THOSE FEW
INITIAL COUNTIES.
BUT THE PROGRAM AS I STATED
BEFORE GREW RAPIDLY WITH THAT
ADDITIONAL THIRTY TWO COUNTIES
BRINGING OUR TOTAL THIRTY NINE
BETWEEN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND THE WORKLOAD FOR
MODIFYING MAINTAINING AND
GATHERING SIGNATURES FOR AND
WILL USE DID NOT KEEP UP AT THE
SAME PACE.
THERE WAS AN ATTEMPT BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO MANDATE SHOP SB
TEN SEVENTY NINE IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN BUT IT WAS HELD IN
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
ABSENT LEGISLATION MANDATING THE
USE OF CHOP AND RESOURCES FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO PERFORM THE
TYPE ABOUT REACHED THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR REPORT
SUGGESTS.
THE ABILITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO DIVERT FUNDS FROM OTHER
CRITICAL NEEDS AND MANDATE SUCH
A SAFETY THE CAL DNA DATA BANK
AT CETERA WILL BE EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT AND AS A RESULT BE
INSUFFICIENT.
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S OFFICE HAVE
BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF ONE TIME
SOLUTIONS TO FILL GAPS IN
FUNDING OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS?
THESE SOLUTIONS ONLY ADDRESS
CURRENT WORKLOADS ON A YEAR TO
YEAR BASIS AS THE D. ANY ID FUND
CONTINUES TO REMAIN VOLATILE AND
THERE'S LITTLE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPANSIVENESS IS WITHOUT A MORE
PERMANENT SOLUTION AN ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES.
AS PREVIOUSLY STATED THE D. ANY
ID FUND HAS DECREASED BY 27%
BETWEEN FISCAL YEARS FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN TO NOW.
AND THAT DECREASE EQUATED TO
MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH IS REFLECTED IN
THE JANUARY BUDGET RELEASED BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S OFFICE.
I CAN TALK FOR A SECOND ABOUT
SAFETY -- THE SEXUAL ASSAULT
FORENSIC EVIDENCE TRACKING
DATABASE IN RESPONSE TO THE
STATE AUDITOR'S AUDIT IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN THE BEER FRANTIC
SERVICES CREATED A DATABASE FOR
TRACKING SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE
KIT STATEWIDE.
AS THE SCOPE AS WE'VE HEARD OF
THE SEXUAL SOCKET INVENTORY.
AND WHEN I SAY INVENTORY THOSE
THINGS THAT ARE SITTING AT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WAS UNKNOWN.
THIS WOULD PROVIDE A PERSPECTIVE
EVALUATION OF ALL KIDS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR TRACKING STATUS
REPORTING.
SAFETY WAS CREATED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN FOR THAT PURPOSE SAFETY
DOES NOT TRACK ANY PERSONALLY
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION.
AND ASSEMBLY BILL AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY EIGHT WAS INTRODUCED TO
MANDATE THE ENTRY INTO SAFETY
BUT WAS ALSO HELD THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS HOWEVER AN
ADDITIONAL EFFORT. TO MANDATE
SAFETY AB FORTY ONE WAS
INTRODUCED IN THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SESSION.
THE BILL PASSED THE MANDATED THE
TRACKING OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
EVIDENCE KIDS WITHIN A HUNDRED
TWENTY DAYS OF COLLECTION.
AND THAT MANDATE BEGAN JANUARY
FIRST OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN WITH
OUR FIRST REPORT DUE TO THE
LEGISLATURE SOMETIME THIS YEAR --
ON THE DATABASE ITSELF -- BOY
THAT'S JULY OF THIS YEAR.
WITH THAT JULY TWENTY NINETEEN
THERE THERE WAS NO SPECIFIC DATE
FOR WHEN WE HAD -- TO PROVIDE IT
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CATCH UP WITH LAGS SINCE THERE
IS A ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAY
PERIOD [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANKS.
TO SO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR INITIATE IS FOLLOW UP ON
IT AROUND THE RECOMMENDATION
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
REPORT CASE CHOP OUTCOME
INFORMATION TO THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THE AUDIT REVIEW THE PROCESS
OF COLLECTING SEXUAL ASSAULT
EVIDENCE KITS.
WHICH MAY CONTAIN DNA EVIDENCE
THAT CAN ASSIST IN THE
INVESTIGATION OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
CASES AS WELL AS THE POTENTIAL
VALUE IN RELATING THOSE OUTCOMES
TO DNA HITS IN THE COMBINED DNA
INDEX SYSTEM.
THE NEW REPORT FOCUSES
EXCLUSIVELY ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND FOLLOW THE TWENTY
FOURTEEN CSA RECOMMENDATIONS.
WHICH IT FINDS MADE INSUFFICIENT
EFFORTS TO OBTAIN CASE OUTCOME
INFORMATION.
THE STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT
REVEALED SOBRE SEVERAL AREAS FOR
IMPROVEMENT IN THE DEPARTMENT'S
RATS PROGRAM.
MAINLY RELATED AROUND THE AMMO
USE AND DISCUSSED OUR UNIQUE
POSITION FOR REPORTING CASE
OUTCOME INFORMATION RELATED TO
HIT NOTIFICATIONS.
I WON'T LIST ALL THE SPECIFIC
ISSUES THAT THE FLAG IS
PRESUMABLY YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF
YOU -- INSTEAD I JUST WANT TO
VERY QUICKLY ADDRESS SOME OF THE
pAPPROPRIATE AND DISCUSS OUR
PLANS MOVING FORWARD.
HISTORICALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S ROLE IN THE FINAL
OUTCOME OF THE CASE IS VERY
LIMITED ONCE THE DNA.
WANTS DNA HAS BEEN PROCESSED
THROUGH THE RATS PROGRAM WE
ENTER THAT INFORMATION INTO
CHOPPER HIT NOTIFICATION.
THERE AFTER AN AUTOMATED EMAIL
SENT TO THE INVESTIGATING AGENCY
AND IT'S AN INCUMBENT UPON THEM
TO GO IN THERE AND RETRIEVE THAT
DNA HIT.
SO THERE'S SINCE THERE'S NO
STATUTORY REQUIREMENT FOR LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO USE AND
ENTERED IT INTO CHOP DOJ'S
ABILITY TO ENSURE PARTICIPATION
BY THE LOCAL AGENCIES IS LIMIT.
IN OUR ENFORCEMENT.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE THROUGH AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTEEN ESTABLISHED THE NEED
FOR RAPID TURNAROUND -- DNA
PROGRAM AND REQUIRED THE USE OF
A WRITTEN AGREEMENT WHICH WE
USED AS A DEMO YOU.
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT THE
CRIME LABORATORY AND THE MEDICAL
FACILITY WHERE THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT TEAM IS BASED.
PURSUANT TO THE AUDIT WAS
SUGGESTED THAT WE CHANGE THE
LANGUAGE IN THE M. O. U.
REQUIRING CHOP PARTICIPATION FOR
AGENCIES USING THE RATS PROGRAM
[inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
DOESN'T HAVE AN ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM IF SOMEBODY VIOLATES
AN AMMO YOU.
WE CAN ASK AGAIN BUT WE CAN'T
ENFORCE THE MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING.
SEC DOING THINGS LIKE NOT
PROCESSING PROCESSING THEIR
CASES IN ENFORCEMENT IS NOT
REALLY SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO
DO BECAUSE THAT DOESN'T HELP
VICTIMS IT DOESN'T HELP THE
PUBLIC AND SO WE CONTINUE TO
TAKE THEIR CASES REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE ENTERING.
THE CASE SAID OUTCOME
INFORMATION.
AND AS A RESULT SINCE TWENTY
FOURTEEN WE HAVE REPORTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE THAT OBTAINING CASE
OUTCOMES IS AN UP HILL BATTLE
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF A
STATUTORY MANDATE TO COLLECT
THEM.
AND WE'VE SEEN WERE STATUTORILY
MANDATED ENTRY INTO A DATABASE
USING SAFETY AS A PROXY.
IS MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN
COMPLIANCE AFTER ONLY ONE YEAR
WE ARE SEEING A HIGH PERCENTAGE
OF COMPLIANCE FOR THE CASES THAT
ARE ENTERED INTO SAFETY WITH A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAY MANDATE.
SO I'LL CONCLUDE -- WE AGREE
WITH THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT A STATUTORY
MANDATE TO REQUIRE ENTRY OF CASE.
CASE OUTCOME DATA INTO CHOP IS
NEEDED AS TO THE OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS.
DOJ IS COMMITTED TO DOING
EVERYTHING WITHIN OUR LIMITED
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THE
INFORMATION REPORTS OBTAINED.
ARE OBTAINED FROM LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND TO THAT
END WERE ALREADY IN THE PROCESS
OF DRAFTING A WHAT WE CALL
PHYSICAL EVIDENCE BILL AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE PUT OUT
PUBLICLY TO OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES IS TO OUR EXPECTATIONS
OF THEM. FOR US ANALYZING THEIR
EVIDENCE.
WHERE DRAFTING INFORMATION BILL
AND FOR ALL THOSE CLAN AGENCIES
THAT WILL BE AVAILABLE -- IN OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT NETWORK.
AS WELL AS REVIEWING THE
FEASIBILITY OF GENERATING A
GATHERING SIGNATURES ON AND WILL
USE FROM EVERY PARTICIPATING
AGENCY IN THE THIRTY NINE RATS
COUNTIES.
THIS IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT
EFFORT BECAUSE COUNTIES
OBVIOUSLY HAVE MULTIPLE
SIGNATORIES A DISTRICT ATTORNEY
A SHARE OF MULTIPLE LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENTS.
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS MUNICIPAL
HEADS -- ALL OF THOSE HAVE TO BE
LOOKED DOWN INTO.
AND WE'RE WORKING TO ENSURE THAT
OUR TRAINING INCLUDES MODULES ON
SHOP IN OUR EXPECTATIONS FOR
ENTRY BEYOND THESE EFFORTS WE
WELCOME THE LEGISLATURE SUPPORT
FOR ADDITIONAL STAFF AND
RESOURCES THAT WILL HELP ENSURE
THE SUCCESS OF RATS AND CHOP --
EFFORTS THAT WE KNOW WILL
ULTIMATELY HELP VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S CUT AND MOVE ON
WILL TAKE ALL TESTIMONY AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE TO QUESTIONS.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU I'M
NANCY O'MALLEY THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OF ALAMEDA COUNTY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING AND FOR ALLOWING ME TO
BE PART OF IT.
I WANT TO SHARE THAT WHEN IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WHEN I WAS
IN COLLEGE I WAS A RAPE CRISIS
VOLUNTEER.
I WAS ONE OF THE VOLUNTEERS WHO
WAS ON WAS WITH A VICTIM OF THE
GOLDEN STATE KILLER.
AND SO I'VE BEEN WORKING IN THIS
AREA SINCE THAT TIME AND IS ONE
OF THE REASONS I BECAME A
PROSECUTOR WAS TO CHANGE THE
INJUSTICES THAT WERE OCCURRING.
TO VICTIMS OF INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
IN IN TWO THOUSAND AND TEN I HAD
A CALL FROM SOMEONE FROM SANTA
CRUZ WHO HAD A INDICATED THAT
HER KID HAD BEEN.
SITTING ON A SHELF IN THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT SHERIFF DEPARTMENT
FOR SEVEN MONTHS AND HOW RATE
JUST THAT WAS.
THAT PROMPTED ME TO START A
PROJECT IN MY OWN COUNTY.
BUT BEFORE I STARTED THE PROJECT
IN MY COUNTY WENT TO NEW YORK
CITY TO SEE WHAT THEY DID
BECAUSE THEY HAD TEN THOUSAND
UNTESTED KIDS.
AND THEY WERE MANAGING HOW THEY
WERE GOING TO TEST THOSE KIDS.
IN ADDITION TO TRYING TO
IDENTIFY PEOPLE WOULD BEEN
KILLED IN NINE ELEVEN THE NINE
ELEVEN ATTACK SO THAT A LOT OF
WORK THEY WERE DOING AND YET
THEY WERE MANAGING.
TO ELIMINATE THE BACKLOG AND
KEEP UP WITH THEIR CURRENT WORK.
SO I WANTED TO KNOW WHAT IT WAS
THAT THEY WERE DOING THAT WAS
RIGHT.
AND I CAME BACK AND I CAST TO
PROSECUTORS IN MY OFFICE TO WORK
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND I WANT TO MAKE THE POINT
THAT I DO BELIEVE THE
PROSECUTORS THE DA THE ELECTED
DA HAS AN IMPORTANT ROLE.
IN THEIR COUNTIES EACH OF OUR
COUNTIES TO WORK WITH OUR LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT PARTICULARLY IN
MANY OF THE COUNTIES WHERE THERE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IS REALLY
THE SHERIFF'SDEPARTMENT.
BECAUSE OF THE SIZE OF THEIR
COUNTY SO I DO THINK THAT THE DA
HAS AN IMPORTANT ROLE TO PLAY.
AND THE TWO STAFF MY TWO
ATTORNEYS WORKED WITH EVERYONE
OF OUR POLICE AGENCIES TO
IDENTIFY HOW MANY UNTESTED KIDS
THEY HAD IN THEIR PROPERTY ROOM.
IT TOOK US ABOUT A YEAR AND I
WILL SAY THAT THE CITY OF
OAKLAND WHO WAS PART OF THE
ORIGINAL AUDIT.
WAS THE MOST -- RESISTANT TO OUR
EFFORTS AND EVENTUALLY IT BECAME
MORE A POLITICAL ISSUE.
WHERE THE MAYOR GOT INVOLVED THE
CITY MANAGER GOT INVOLVED AND
THEY ORDERED THE CRIME LAB
DIRECTOR TO PARTICIPATE IN OUR
PROGRAM?
WHICH THEY EVENTUALLY DID AND
WHAT WE DISCOVERED WAS A HAD
ALMOST NINE HUNDRED UNTESTED
KIDS.
AND THEIR CRIME LAB IS IN THE
SAME BUILDING AS OUR EVIDENCE
ROOM.
SO FOR ME -- YOU KNOW I CONTAIN
MY OUTRAGE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
MOVED FORWARD AND WORK
COLLABORATIVELY -- AND WE
STARTED THE EFFORT. TO START
IDENTIFYING THIS KITCHEN FIGURE
AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO TAKE CARE
OF IT.
I FOUND MONEY THROUGH -- FOR
FUTURE UNRESTRICTED FOR FUTURE
DOLLARS AND I PAID FOR THE FIRST
ROUND OF TESING WE DID NOT GO
THROUGH OUR GOVERNMENT CRIME LAB.
THEY WERE FRANKLY TOO SLOW.
AND THEY WOULD TAKE SIX MONTHS
AND THEY WERE CHARGING LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
MORE MONEY THAN MANY OF THE
AGENCIES HAD.
SO WE GOT IN TOUCH WITH THE
COMPANY WE MET HIM THROUGH
NATASHA YOU'RE GONNA MEET IN A
FEW MINUTES. TO THE NATASHA
PROJECT BODHI LAB IN VIRGINIA
AND WE CONTRACT WITH THEM AND
THEY DID THEY HAVE DONE ALL OF
OUR BACKLOG TESTING.
THE FIRST GROUP WE SENT THEM ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN KIDS.
AND IN ONE MONTH'S TIME THEY HAD
COMPLETED THEIR REVIEW OF THOSE
HUNDRED SIXTEEN THE TESTING WE
HAD FIFTY ONE PROFILES
IDENTIFIED AND ADDED THAT IN THE
FIRST WEEKEND THAT IT WAS IN
CODIS.
WHICH ALSO FEEDS INTO THE BIG
STATE DOT DOJ -- DATABASE FEEDS
INTO THE NATIONAL IN THAT FIRST
WEEK IN MAY TWENTY SEVEN HITS ON
THE FIFTY ONE PROFILES THAT WE
SUBMITTED.
SO WE KNOW THE SIGNIFICANCE THAT
DISPLAYS IN BEING ABLE TO
IDENTIFY PERPETRATORS. TO
IDENTIFY SERIAL RAPIST AND MARK
AS IMPORTANTLY WHAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER POINTED OUT TO
EXONERATE PEOPLE WHO WERE
IDENTIFIED BY.
THE THROUGH THE EYE WITNESS
TESTIMONY WHICH TURNED OUT TO BE
FLOOD.
OR PEOPLE THAT WERE CHARGED THAT
HAD NOT ACTUALLY COMMITTED THE
CRIME.
SINCE THAT TIME -- WE WE CREATED
AN ENTIRE -- INITIATIVE CALLED
ELIMINATE THE BACKLOG.
WE SHARE THIS AROUND THE STATE
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND IT HAD
SEVERAL COMPONENTS NOT JUST
ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET
THESE TO THESE KIDS TESTED IN A
TIMELY MANNER.
BUT ONE OF THE OTHER BACKLOGS
THAT EXIST IS THAT WHEN A
PRIVATE LAB -- WHICH FOR US WAS
BODHI WHICH WAS PROCESSING A
HUNDRED KIDS A MONTH FOR US --
THAT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN WITH THAT
BEFORE THE DNA PROFILE COULD GO
INTO THE DATABASE.
SOMEONE FROM A GOVERNMENT CRIME
LET WOULD HAVE TO REVIEW THE
REPORT.
NOW I KNOW A LOT ABOUT THIS AND
I READ A LOT OF THESE REPORTS
AND THEY'RE PRETTY MUCH THE SAME
REPORT WITH THE BOTTOM LINE
BEING DIFFERENT WHICH WHOEVER
THE PROFILE IS.
BUT IN THE HOUSTON WHEN I WENT
AND VISITED THEIR LAB IT WAS
TAKING THEM THREE YEARS JUST TO
REVIEW THE REPORTS.
SO THERE WAS NOT ONLY A BACKLOG
OF KIDS NOT BEINGTESTED BUT
THEN THREE YEARS TO GET THROUGH
ALL THE REPORTS.
AND WE WE HAVE RECEIVED SPECIAL
FUNDING WE DID RECEIVE.
A SPECIAL FUNDING TO PAY FOR
SOMEONE IN THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT TO REVIEW OUR REPORT
WE NOW HAVE NO BACKLOG AND WE
ALSO IN ADDITION TO HAVING NO
BACKLOG WE ALSO SET UP A SYSTEM
WHERE WE ARE ACCOUNTABLE EACH OF
US -- ACCOUNTABLE FOR WHAT
HAPPENS WE KNOW EVERY EXAM
THAT'S DONE I GET A REPORT EVERY
MONTH.
I KNOW HOW MANY KIDS ARE HOW
MANY REPORTS.
OF SEXUAL SORRY PORTS ARE MADE
TO EACH LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY I
KNOW WHETHER OR NOT THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY HAS REQUESTED
OR OTHERS AUTHORIZED THE KID TO
BE DONE OR AN EXAM.
WE KNOW WHETHER OR NOT IT'S BEEN
SUBMITTED AND SO I CAN KEEP
TRACK OF THAT IN THE DATA KEEPS
PEOPLE KEEP ALL OF US
ACCOUNTABLE.
BUT I DIDN'T SHOULD STOP THERE.
BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS I DID
WAS I WENT TO WASHINGTON DC AND
AS A RESULT OF THE WORK THAT WE
DID IN WASHINGTON WHITE A
MEETING AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
EXPLAIN THE BACKLOG IN THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROPERTY ROOMS.
WE DID A DIAGRAM FOR THEM AND
THEY UNDERSTOOD AND PRESENT A
MAMA PUT MONEY IN HIS BUDGET FOR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT ACROSS OUR
NATION.
THAT IS CONTINUED AND NOW
THERE'S OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT HAS
BEEN ALLOCATED TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT DOJ HAS BEEN THE
RECIPIENT OF SOME OF THAT MONEY.
I KNOW AND MY AND IT IS STILL IN
THE IN THE NEW THE UPCOMING
BUDGET FOR THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR
OF NINETEEN TWENTY FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ANOTHER FORTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. FOR LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT SO THE THE PART
SO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
PUT THEIR RESOURCES.
INTO A LOT OF RESOURCES FOR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT NOT ONLY
TO TEST KITS BUT TO SET UP
PROCEDURES.
LIKE MINE IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
WHERE THERE IS NEVER GOING TO BE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR BACK LOVE TO
HER AGAIN.
OF THE SAFETY DATABASE -- THAT
WAS JUST TALK ABOUT IT WAS OF
LEGISLATION THAT I SPONSORED AND
I THINK IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE NOT ONLY ARE
THE PROPERTY ROOMS LOGGING IN I
MEAN ONE OF THE BIGGEST PITFALLS
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT IS WHAT
HAPPENS WITH PROPERTY.
AND EVIDENCE SO IT'S LOGGED IN
ITS VERY CAREFULLY MONITORED.
IT'S JUST A FEW MORE KEYSTROKES
TO LOG INTO THE SAFETY DATABASE
AND THAT WE WERE ALWAYS GOING TO
KNOW WITH THE CLICK OF A A QUERY
TO FIND OUT HOW MANY KIDS ARE IN
THE CRIME LAB.
I DO BELIEVE THAT -- THAT WE
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO BUT THE
TECHNOLOGY IS MOVING SO FAST
THAT I BELIEVE THAT SOME OF OUR
CRIME LABS HAVE NOT KEPT UP DOJ
IS ACTUALLY OUR MODEL. FOR
TESTING EQUIPMENT TO LET OTHERS
ARE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND THE CRIME LABS KNOW
THAT THIS IS EQUIPMENT THAT WILL
HELP BE MORE EFFICIENT.
REQUIRES FEWER CRIMINALISTS I
MEAN THERE HAS TO BE
CRIMINALISED BUT A LOT OF IT IS
DONE BEING DONE.
BY TECHNICIANS WERE ASSISTING
THE CRIMINALIST TO GO THROUGH
THE TECHNOLOGY THROUGH ROBOTICS
AND OTHER THINGS LIKE THAT.
I AND THAT'S THOSE ARE WAYS THAT
FOR ALL OF THE THE NUMBER OF
SEXUAL SOLVE CRIMES WHICH IS
STAGGERING.
STILL -- THAT THAT IS OUR
ABILITY TO TAP INTO THE
TECHNOLOGY.
THAT OCCURRED IN OF THIS ALL
STARTED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
WHEN.
BILL LOCKYER WAS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WHO PUT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS INTO CREATING THE
INFRASTRUCTURES OF DNA.
OF LABS TO DO DNA WORK AND WE'RE
STILL HERE AND WE STILL HAVE
KIDS THAT ARE UNTESTED.
SO -- THIS IS AN EFFORT THAT I
AM SO THANKFUL THAT THE THE
AUDITS THAT WERE DONE TO GIVE
FOCUS TO THIS I DO I AM
SPONSORING NOW THE LEGISLATION
TO REQUIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT. TO
SUBMIT ALL KIDS TO BE TESTED AND
WE LAST YEAR WE GOT TO THE
LEGISLATURE WITHOUT ANY NO VOTES
BUT THE GOVERNOR VETOED IT.
AT THE LAST MINUTE THIS YEAR WE
HOPE THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND CHANGE THAT
PARADIGM -- AND THEN JUST ONE
MORE THING TO JUST REITERATE IS
THAT I DO BELIEVE THAT THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S IN EACH
COUNTY SHOULD STEP UP.
AND EXERCISE OUR LEADERSHIP
THERE THE CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER IN THE COUNTIES AND THEY
HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH
EVERYONE OF THEIR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
AND THAT'S THE PLACE WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO GET THINGS DONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS.
PLEASE LET'S CONTINUE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS MORGAN GEYER AND I'M A
SUPERVISING DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FOR THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY DA'S OFFICE.
DOCTOR REPRESENT BEHIND ME I'M
GOING TO APOLOGIZE READING MY
BACK DOOR.
I WILL ECHO SOME OF THE COMMENTS
OF DISTRICT ATTORNEY O'MALLEY
AND BRIEFLY DESCRIBE THE
SACRAMENTO PROCESS AS WELL --
FIRST I SUPERVISE OUR JUSTICE
TRAINING INTEGRITY DIVISION OF
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
WHICH COVERS -- I OVERSEE OUR
CONVICTION REVIEW PROGRAM AND
OUR REQUESTS FOR POST CONVICTION
DNA TESTING -- NEARLY TWENTY
YEARS AGO WE BEGAN.
THE INNOVATIVE PROCESS OF HAVING
THE SEXUAL ASSAULT KITS.
SUBMITTED DIRECTLY TO OUR CRIME
LAB SACRAMENTO COUNTY HAS ITS
OWN.
LABORATORY FORENSIC SERVICES
THAT IS RUN THROUGH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND THOSE KIDS
FOR THE LAST TWENTY YEARS HAVE
BEEN SUBMITTED DIRECTLY. TO THE
CRIME LAB -- IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN WE BEGAN THE POLICY OF
TESTING EVERY KID THAT WE HAD
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT
THERE HAD BEEN A REQUEST FROM
LAW ENFORCEMENT -- JUST PUT IT
IN PERSPECTIVE WE RECEIVE
BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY TO
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY SEXUAL
SOCKETS PER YEAR -- SO WE BEGAN
THE PROCESS OF GOING BACK
THROUGH THE ONES THAT HAD BEEN
DECIDED NOT TO BE TESTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERY KID WAS TESTED.
CURRENTLY AS IT STANDS TODAY --
WE ARE CURRENT BACK THROUGH TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN AND FROM TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT PRIOR SO WE
HAVE TWO THOUSAND AND NINE IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN WITH SOME
REMAINING KITS.
THE TWO THOUSAND AND NINE KIDS
HAVE ALL BEEN ASSIGNED TO OUR
ANALYSTS AND HAVE BEEN
INTEGRATED INTO THEIR CASELOADS.
AND WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO KITS
REMAINING FROM TWO THOUSAND TEN
IT'LL BE COMPLETED WELL BEFORE
THE END OF THE YEAR -- AND THAT
WILL KEEP US CURRENT IT IT TAKES
US ROUGHLY -- WITHIN FORTY FIVE
DAYS TO TOUCH TEST EACH SEXUAL
ASSAULT KIT -- IT.
OUR PROCESS OF OF DIRECTLY
RECEIVING THOSE KIDS INTO OUR
CRIME LAB REMOVE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS WERE ADDRESSED BY THE
AUTHOR ABOUT SOME OF THE ISSUES
WHY KIDS ARE TESTED.
UP OCCASIONALLY THE EXCEPTIONS
WOULD BE IF THERE'S IF IT'S
DETERMINED THAT NO CRIME HAS
BEEN COMMITTED WHATSOEVER ON
THOSE SORT OF OR ON A CASE BY
CASE BASIS.
BUT EVEN IF THERE'S NO REQUEST
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT.
OUR COUNTY TEST THOSE KITS
REGARDLESS.
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S MUCH IN
DISPUTE THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE
INFORMATION THAT CAN BE
DEVELOPED FROM THOSE CATS -- AS
MR O'MALLEY MENTIONED EARLIER --
ONE NOT NEED LOOK FARTHER THAN
THE GOLDEN STATE KILLER EAST
AREA RAPIST CASE AS AN EXAMPLE.
ON THE CASE HAD GONE FOR COLD
FOR FORTY YEARS THERE WERE
THIRTEEN MURDERS AND OUR FIFTY
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND BURGLARIES
COMMITTED -- BY A MAN WHO
TERRORIZED OUR STATE AND IT WAS
DNA THAT KEPT THAT CASE FROM
BEING UNSOLVED ARE THERE ARE.
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECTED BY JUST
THIS ONE CASE BUT ULTIMATELY WAS
SOLVED THROUGH THIS VERY
IMPORTANT -- PIECE OF TECHNOLOGY
THAT WERE WE CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF AND I WOULD ECHO DR WEBER'S
COMMENTS AND RETURNING
O'MALLEY'S COMMENTS IN THAT.
IT'S HELPFUL TO SOLVE OUR CASES
IT'S VERY HELPFUL TO PROVIDE
EXONERATIONS AND REMOVE THE
CLOUD OF SUSPICION.
WHEN YOU JUST THINKING CONTEXT
OF THE GOLDEN STATE KILLER CASE
HOW MANY PEOPLE WERE IDENTIFIED
AS POTENTIAL SUSPECTS -- JUST
GIVEN THE NUMBER OF CRIMES THAT
WERE COMMITTED AND TO BE ABLE TO
USE OF THESE.
USE THE PROFILE WITH THAT ARE
DEVELOPING THESE KIDS TO BE ABLE
TO ELIMINATE THE CLOUD OF
SUSPICION IS IS INVALUABLE -- SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE HAVE.
LONG BEEN IN SUPPORT OF TESTING
EVERY KID THAT COMES IN -- I AND
I THINK THAT'S THE MOST
EFFICIENT WAY TO DO IT ON I
WOULD ECHO THE OTHER COMMENTS OF
JUST RETURNING O'MALLEY AND BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR
DISCUSS FURTHER.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THINK FOR TESTIMONY.
WE'RE ALSO JOINED BY SENATOR
BILL SENT CENTER THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US AS WELL.
YEAH THE ROADS WERE IN THE
FINANCE COMMITTEE.
YES AS I EARNED.
AND SIR BORDERS ALSO JOINED US
BUT I THINK HE HAD RUN TO
ANOTHER COMMITTEE -- TO VOTE OR
PRESENT ON A BILL.
SO IT'S IS A SEASON -- THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE TESTIMONY --
GIVE US A VALLEY AND MISTER GUY
YOU GUYS TALKED ABOUT.
THE BACKLOG I THINK IT WAS WAS
SOME ELEY SUBJECT NINETEEN
HUNDRED AT ONE TIME BUT YOU'VE
WORKED THROUGH THAT
SYSTEMATICALLY -- WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IS GET MY ARMS AROUND.
WHAT YOU GUYS SAID WHY WE DON'T
SEE THAT IN EVERY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY?
UP AND DOWN THE ENTIRE STATE AND
DOJ'S.
SEEN SOME OF THIS INFORMATION
BUT YOU TALKED ABOUT FEDERAL
FUNDING IN GOING TO DC IN
GETTING FEDERAL REALLY JUST A
RESOURCE QUESTION OR IS THIS.
I MEAN WHAT ELSE IS LACKING OR
WHAT I TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT.
AT THROUGH STATURE DO WE DO HERE
AT THE STATE YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
WE HAD LEGISLATION PREVIOUSLY
YOU HELP SPONSOR SOME
LEGISLATION AS WELL WE HAVE
CURRENT -- LEGISLATION IN THE
SENATE SENATE BILL TWENTY TWO
RIGHT -- TRYING TO GET MY ARMS
JUST AROUND THAT PIECE OF
PERHAPS MISTER DYER MISS AMOUNT
IF YOU CAN JUST ADDRESS THAT.
IN A LOT OF THE RESEARCH THAT I
DID WAS TALKING TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
NOT JUST IN MY COUNTY BUT IN
CALIFORNIA CROSS COUNTRY.
AND FOR A LOT OF THE OFFICERS TO
DO THE INVESTIGATION THEY WOULD
PUT THE KID.
IN THEIR EVIDENCE ROOM.
AND THAT WOULD BE THE LAST TIME
A POLICE OFFICER WOULD EVER
TOUCH IT THE NEXT PERSON TO
TOUCH IT WOULD BE A CRIME LAB
ANALYST.
AND SO THERE'S A DISK THERE HAS
BEEN A DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE
OFFICERS.
WHO ARE DOING THE A PRIMARY
INVESTIGATION AND MAKING SURE
THAT KID GETS TO THE CRIME LAB
OR LIKE IN THE CASE OF OAKLAND?
WHERE THEIR LAB IS IN THE SAME
BUILDING AS THEIR PROPERTY ROOM?
THAT SOMEBODY FROM THE LAB WOULD
HAVE TO GO DOWN AND TAKE THAT
PROPERTY OUT AND TAKE IT UP TO
BE.
A TO BE EXAMINED SO I THINK THAT
THERE'S BEEN A DISCONNECT
BETWEEN THE CRIME LABS AND THE
THE INVESTIGATING OFFICERS.
THE SECOND PART IS.
I THINK THAT THERE'S BEEN A MIS
UNDERSTANDING OR A MYTH THAT IF
SOMEBODY IDENTIFIES ARE NO SIR
PERPETRATOR WHICH IS SIGNIFICANT
PERCENTAGE OF SEXUAL SOLVE
CRIMES ARE COMMITTED BY SOMEONE
KNOWN. TO THE SURVIVOR.
BUT WHAT WHAT GETS LOST IN THERE
SO WHY WOULD YOU TEST THE DNA IF
YOU ALREADY KNOW THE
IDENTIFICATION.
BUT WHAT WE FOUND IN TESTING
KITS ACROSS AMERICA IS THAT
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE
SERIAL RAPIST.
AND JUST YOU'LL -- IF YOU
HAVEN'T SEEN THE MOVIE I AM
EVIDENCE DONE BY MERCY HERE QUE
YOU MAY HEAR ABOUT THAT IN THE
NEXT PANEL.
THAT REALLY REFLECTS HOW MANY
SERIAL RAPISTS THEY WERE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY.
BY EVEN THOUGH ONE OF THE THEY
ROUTE ONE RATE THAT CAME TO
THEIR ATTENTION.
WAS -- COMMITTED AGAINST
SOMEBODY KNOWN BY THE
PERPETRATOR.
SO THIS IS AN IMPORTANT POINT
BECAUSE IT NOT ONLY IS YOU KNOW
THE OFFICERS LOOK AT ONE CASE AT
A TIME.
AND DNA HAS SHOWN IS THAT THERE
ARE MANY CASES IN MY OWN COUNTY
MY OWN COUNTY IN BERKELEY --
THERE WAS A SEXUAL SOLVE CRIME.
SHE SUBMITTED TO AN EXAM AND
NEVER GOT SUBMITTED FOR TESTING.
THE SECOND SEXUAL ASSAULT CRIME
HAPPENED AND THAT THAT VICTIM
WAS MURDERED.
THE THIRD SEXUAL SAW CRIME
HAPPENED AND THE THAT WOMAN
SUBMITTED TO TESTING.
AND WHEN WE FINALLY WENT TO
BERKELEY AND SAID GIVE US ALL
YOUR KIDS -- THAT WE TESTED WE
FOUND IT WAS THE SAME PERSON.
AND THIS IS THE TOO MANY
EXAMPLES OF THAT SO I DON'T I
THINK THAT WE AGAIN THIS IS A
PLACE WHERE I THINK THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS HAVE AN IMPORTANT ROLE
TO PLAY.
I THINK THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO AROUND.
A TRAINING DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
AND PROSECUTORS WHO ARE
REVIEWING CASES FOR WHETHER
THERE IS SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE TO
PROSECUTE.
BUT IMPORTANTLY I THINK THAT
THERE HAS TO BE.
MUCH MORE COORDINATION AN
EMPHASIS ON SOMEONE HAS TO TAKE
THE LEAD SO EVEN THOUGH THE THE
CRIME THE PROPERTY ROOM.
MANAGERS WILL ENTER INTO SAFETY.
THAT IF THAT DOUBLE INFINITE
KNOW WHATEVER CHECKS THAT
DATABASE THEN IT'S JUST THERE
SITTING THERE LIKE WE'VE SEEN
OVER THE YEARS.
AND SO I DID I DO BELIEVE THAT
THE I DON'T I THINK THE
LEGISLATION TO REQUIRE ALL TEST
KITS TO BE TESTED.
IS REALLY IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
I ALSO THINK THAT TAPPING INTO
THE MODERN -- TECHNOLOGY THAT
EXISTS TO ASSIST THE CRIME LABS
TO BE MORE EFFICIENT IN THEIR
TESTING.
AND AND ACTUALLY AND I AND THIS
ISSUE ABOUT.
AN OUTSIDE LAB WHO ARE OFTEN
TIMES.
COST LESS MONEY THAN THE
GOVERNMENT LABS DO.
OUR FASTER AND YOU KNOW FRANKLY --
YOU KNOW IF THEY MAKE A MISTAKE
THEY'RE OUT OF BUSINESS AND SO
WE'VE SEEN -- WITH THE LAB THAT
WE WORK WITH A LOT OF VERY GOOD --
ACCOUNTABILITY.
BUT IF IT TAKES THREE YEARS TO
REVIEW A REPORT REVIEW REPORTS
THEN WE ARE NOT SOLVING THE
PROBLEM.
SO WE ACTUALLY HAVE A PILOT THAT
WE'VE PITCH TO THE FBI. TO SEE
IF WE CAN DO SOME WORK AROUND.
REDUCING THE TIME THAT IT TAKES
TWO TO REVIEW THOSE REPORT TO
GET THESE PROFILES INTO THE
NATIONAL DATABASE FASTER
[inaudible]
SO.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
SO DO YOU HAVE.
GIVE A POLICY NOW IT HAS ALL
YOUR KIDS AND WE DO YOU DO.
I THINK MR GEYER SAID YOU SAID
YOU WHICH SAID IT DIRECTLY
THOUGH RIGHT TO THE LAB THE WHEN
THE WHEN THE FORENSIC MEDICAL
EXAM IS COMPLETED AT OUR WHAT WE
CALL OUR BEAR CENTER AT OUR AT
OUR FORENSIC MEDICAL.
CENTER THOSE KIDS ARE THEN.
TAKEN DIRECTLY TO OUR CRIME LAB.
SO IT NEVER GOES TO THAT NEVER
GOES TO AN EVIDENCE LOCKER NEVER
GOES LAW ENFORCEMENT FACILITY IT
MAY BE TRANSPORTED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT BUT IT GOES DIRECTLY
TO OUR LAB.
AS SOON AS THE TESTING IS
COMPLETED.
SO ANY ANY ANY.
UNTESTED KIDS OR RESULT OF OUR
DECISION NOT TO HAVE DONE THAT
FOR OUR DIVISION OF RESOURCES
THAT WE HAVE NOW BEEN ABLE.
TO ELIMINATE AND AN AD. TO THE
CASE LOADS OF OUR ANALYSTS TO
GET THOSE CASES DOWN AND I WOULD
I WOULD ECHO WHAT.
MS O'MALLEY SAID THAT IT IN OUR
EXPERIENCE IT WAS SORT OF OUT OF
SORT OF A PHILOSOPHY SHIFT AWAY
FROM JUST SOLVING THE CASE THIS
CASE WAS A CONSENT CASE THIS
CASE WAS A SPOUSAL RAPE CASE AND
AS AS DISTRICT ATTORNEY O'MALLEY
POINTED OUT.
WE'VE SPENT OUR CAREERS
PROSECUTING SEX CRIME CASES AND
AND IT AND IT'S TRUE THAT
SOMEONE WHO.
COMMITS A SPOUSAL RAPE WILL ALSO
RAPE A STRANGER -- AND THAT THE
OVERLAP OF THOSE CASES IS IS ON
DOUBTED AND THE NEED FOR IT IS
CRITICAL.
CAN I JUST ADD THAT.
IN SEVERAL OF THE A FEW OF THE
COUNTIES WE DON'T USE THE DOJ
LAB ANYMORE BECAUSE WE HAVE OUR
OWN CRIME LET THE SHERIFF'S HAS
ONE OAKLAND POLICE HAS AND HAS
THEIR OWN.
SAME THING IN LOS ANGELES LAPD
HAS AROUND LA SHERIFF HAS HIS --
AND SO THERE ARE IN LA THERE'S
AN ORDINANCE THAT THEY HAVE TO
TEST THE KIDS AND THEY THEIR
TIME LINE IS THE SAME AS THE
LEGISLATION -- AND WHEN WE ARE
CRAFTING THAT LEGISLATION WE'VE
REACHED OUT TO THEM.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF KIDS TWO OF FOR AN
AGENCY.
TO WHAT WOULD IT TAKE WHAT CAN
THEY DO WHAT'S REALISTIC --
ORANGE COUNTY TESOL THEIR KIDS
LA TESTS ALL THEIR KIDS SO THERE
ARE INDEED AND NOW WILL COMPLETE
OAKLAND POLICE ALSO TESTS ALL
THEIR KIDS.
SO THERE BEEN A LOT OF THOSE
REALLY SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN
THE THE BIGGER LABS THAT ARE
CONNECTED TO A POLICE DEPARTMENT
OR TO ACCOUNTING LIKE MINE.
A WHERE THE KIDS ARE BEING ARE
BEING TESTED.
SO THE I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT A
LOT OF COUNTIES ARE ACTUALLY
MOVING TOWARDS A MODEL BECAUSE
OF THE CASE OUTCOMES IN THE IF
IT'S RELATED YOU KNOW TO
REPROACH HE BROUGHT UP THE NORTH
CAROLINA.
INCIDENT EARLIER IN THE PREVIOUS
PANEL AND SO -- APPRECIATE THAT
BUT RIGHT NOW YOU. FOR USMLE YOU
DON'T -- SYNDICATE DIRECTLY TO
BE TESTED YOU PUT IT IN EVIDENCE
LOCKER I WAS WONDERING ABOUT
BEST PRACTICES NOW. FOR FOR
MOVING FORWARD IT MAYBE WE THAT
WOULD PROBABLY STREAMLINED IT.
SO SAN MATEO COUNTY GOES RIGHT
FROM THEIR SEXUAL ASSAULT
RESPONSE CENTER.
WHERE THE EXAMS ARE DONE AND
THIS THE KID DOESN'T GO BACK TO
THE POLICE TO GOES DIRECTLY TO
THEIR CRIME LAB -- AND THAT'S
VERY EFFICIENT IN MY COUNTY WE
HAVE TWENTY THREE PLEASE
JURISDICTIONS.
AND SUMMER OAKLAND LOGO THAT
GOES DIRECTLY TO THEIR CRIME LAB
OR TO THEIR EVIDENCE ROOM WHERE
IT'S HELD SECURELY.
AND THEY'RE WITHIN FIVE DAYS
SOMEONE FROM THE CRIME LAB COMES
AND GETS IT.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE CHAIN
OF CUSTODY ALSO TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE.
THAT IS.
HELD IN A UP SOMEWHERE THAT
SAVED.
UP BUT WITH THE WITH THE REST OF
THEM -- WE I DO THINK IT'S A
GOOD IT'S A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
SEND IT DIRECTLY TO THE CRIME
LAB -- AND I THINK THAT.
THAT WAY -- IT HAS TO BE BOOKED
IN.
SOMEWHERE AND YOU KNOW I THINK
YOU KNOW JUST WITH THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND DIFFERENT
MUNICIPALITIES THEY HAVE THEIR
OWN POLICE AGENCY THERE.
MAY BE A ISSUE AROUND THAT BUT
EVERYTHING CAN BE DONE AND I AND
IN OUR COUNTY WE'RE WE'RE REALLY
MOVING MORE TOWARDS THAT.
WITH THE NOT BRINGING IT TO
THEIR EVIDENCE FROM NECESSARILY
OR BOOKING IT AND THEN WITHIN
THREE DAYS DELIVERING IT TO THE
CRIME LAB.
THANK YOU AND CENTER BELL HAS A
QUESTION.
OF JUST THE I'M ON THE BUDGET.
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE SO
THAT'S MY WHY AM HERE ON THIS.
HEARING -- WE'VE WE DISCUSSES
QUITE A BIT LAST YEAR OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS ACTUALLY.
AND OF ALLOCATED MONEY AND AND
SO FORTH. TO HELP EXPEDITE.
OF THE BACKLOG AND BECAUSE
YOU'RE HERE BOTH BOTH YOU I I
WANTED TO FIND OUT -- WHAT IS
YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON THE STATE
BUDGET FOR THOSE OF?
WE WE ALSO HAVE A REQUEST FOR A
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR. FOR ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT PROGRAMS FUNDING.
TO DO MORE OF THE EDUCATION
PREVENTION.
KINDS OF PROGRAMS THAT COULD
HELP.
MAKE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
NEED TO HAVE.
YOU KNOW RICHEST TESTING AND THE
SO FOR US -- AND HOW TO OF
COURSE AVOID SEXUAL SALTS OF AND
DOES THE A BACKLOG NEED
ADDITIONAL AS A BEEN A REQUEST
FROM THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDS. FOR THIS --
ISSUE -- AND YOU KNOW THE
VARIOUS I WANT TO HEAR WHAT
THEY'RE WHAT YOUR OPINION IS ON
THAT.
FROM THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
PERSPECTIVE AND I ALSO I WANTED
I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW COMING FROM
SAN JOSE -- I KNOW THAT YOU
YOU'RE JUST -- THE LEADER IN OUR
STATE. FOR A DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
THAT YOU'VE GIVEN TO ALL OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
WELL -- I KNOW WAS SENATOR LAID
HIS BILL WHICH I'M SPONSORING.
A AND THAT WAS THE SAME WITH
LAST YEAR WHERE THERE WAS MONEY
ALLOCATED THAT YOU'RE
LEGISLATURE DID A GAVE IN THE
GOVERNOR -- CARRIED THROUGH.
OF THERE IS A BUDGET REQUEST
ALSO AND I THINK THAT DID.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS
MODIFIED WHAT THE NEED IS I WANT.
TO SO THE REQUEST THE BUDGET
REQUEST I THINK NOW IS.
800-100-01000 -- FOR AND THAT
WOULD BE FOR THE SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION WAS REALLY TO FOCUS
ON BACKLOG.
BUT THE EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
EIGHT THINK IS TO CONTINUE
MOVING FORWARD.
WITH ALL KIDS BEING TESTED --
AND AND I THINK IT'S BEEN AND IF.
EFFICIENT USE OF THE RESOURCES.
TO HIRE THE CRIMINALISTS WHEN WE
HAD THE DOWNTURN.
IN THE ECONOMY SEVERAL YEARS
BACK A DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAD
TO LAY OFF A LOT OF STAFF AND
THEY COULDN'T HIRE CRIMINALIST.
AND I DON'T SPEAK FOR FOR THEM
BUT I KNOW A LOT ABOUT THE
BUSINESS.
WELL WE WE OUT OF WE HAD IT BACK
A LOT OF OF THE STAFF FOR THAT
YES YES SO I DO THINK THAT'S THE
CASE I ALSO THINK THAT.
OF FOR THOSE LAB FOR THOSE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THAT DO NOT
USE THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND THE POLICY IS IF WE HAVE OUR
OWN CRIME LAB WE CAN'T USE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
OTHER THAN VERY UNUSUAL
CIRCUMSTANCES BUT FOR THOSE
POLICE AGENCIES.
THERE MANY OF THE CRIME LABS ARE
CHARGING THEM THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS ABLE TO NOT CHARGE
DOES COUNTY SAY SIR -- BUT FOR
THE OTHER DEPARTMENTS LIKE LOS
ANGELES AND OURS.
AND IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY JUST
WE HAVE A PRETTY GOOD ONE BRAND
BRAND NEW EXACTLY REALLY KNOW --
BUT THE POLICE BUT THE POLICE
ARE PAYING. TO HAVE THE KIDS
TESTED.
AND BECAUSE IT'S A GOVERNMENT
LAB THERE'S MORE --
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORT THAT'S
NEEDED SO THAT THE COST IS
HIGHER -- THAN SOME OF THESE
OUTSIDE LABS AND SO THERE'S
SOMEWHERE THAT I THINK WE COULD.
GET RESOURCES TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO AT LEAST GET THEM
GOING.
I AND THEN FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
REDUCE THE COST THE WAY SOME OF
THE PRIVATE LABS HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO DO.
I THINK WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL
I'LL TALK TO CENTER SKINNER
WHOSE IT'S THE COMMITTEES
BASICALLY MYSELF CENTER CAN EARN
SIR MORLOCK AND COURSE WE WORK
WITH CENTER LEYVA.
AS WELL.
SO -- IS THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE
DIRECTION MAKING A FORMAL
PROPOSAL TO OUR COMMITTEE.
THE FORMAL PROPOSAL FOR MONEY.
AS WE DO WE DO MONEY.
THAT ARE AVAILABLE AS A PROPOSAL
REAL QUICK YOU HAVE A BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT SOME CLARIFICATION
WE DO HAVE A BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
THE OKAY THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO
THE BACK FILL I'M WE TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER ABOUT THE DNA FUND
HAS BEEN STRUGGLING.
AND IT WAS A PROPOSAL THAT WE
BROUGHT TO THE COMMITTEE LAST
YEAR -- SO THIS YEAR THE
PROPOSAL IS TO EXTEND THAT FOR
ONE MORE YEAR -- BUT WE ARE
SEEKING A LONG TERM SOLUTION --
SO IN WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WITH THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WE'RE HOPEFUL WE CAN
GET TO A LONG TERM SOLUTION BUT
IN THE MEANTIME WE HAVE A
PROPOSAL THAT CARRIES OUT THE
CURRENT SOLUTION ONE MORE YEAR.
YEAH.
YOU THINK THAT THE THE THE
THERE'S ABOUT A DOZEN SENATORS
ARE PROPOSING THE ADDITIONAL
MONEY FOR THE PREVENTION
EDUCATION.
DO YOU THINK -- THAT WOULD --
HELP FACILITATE HOW WHAT IMPACT
YOU THINK THAT WOULD HAVE WELL I
THINK WHAT WHAT WE HAVE NOT
GIVEN AS MUCH FOCUS TO IS AN
IMMENSE ON OTHER THINGS -- AS I
SAID -- MONEY OUT.
ACTUALLY SIXTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
IS ACTUALLY WHAT'S IN THE BUDGET
FOR THAT RIGHT NOW IN THE STATE
BUDGET THAT'S FANTASTIC -- I
WELL IT'S BETTER THAN THAN WHAT
WE'VE BEEN ZERO YES SIR BUT AYE
AYES SHARED EARLIER THAT I WAS A
RAPE CRISIS VOLUNTEER IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX AND AND IT
WAS TERRIBLE.
THEN FOR VICTIMS AND A AND SO IN
AYE WE'RE ALSO GETTING READY FOR
VICTIMS RIGHTS WEEK NEXT WEEK
AND SO I'VE REVIEWED ALL OF THE
LEGISLATURE A VICTIM SERVICES
AND THE FIRST.
VICTIMS RIGHTS LEGISLATION WAS
FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT SURVIVORS IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE AND WE'RE
STILL HERE.
SO WE'RE I THINK THE FIFTY
MILLION OR THE REQUEST -- FOR
PREVENTION IN AND OUT REACH
EDUCATION IS CRITICAL BECAUSE
WHAT WE STILL SEE CONSISTENTLY
IS THAT.
ABOUT -- 5260% OF THE CASES
[inaudible]
ARE UNREPORTED.
WHICH OF FOR A LOT OF REASONS
AND AND SOME OF WHICH IS THAT --
PEOPLE JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE SYSTEM IS ARE THEY
DON'T WANT TO BECOME PUBLIC
ABOUT IT AND WE'VE GOT THE
LEGISLATURE'S CREATE A LOT OF
LAWS TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO REMAIN.
ANONYMOUS IN THE SYSTEM SO I
THINK THAT IF WE CAN INCREASE.
THE NUMBER BECAUSE THROUGH
EDUCATION AND THROUGH -- MORE --
INDIVIDUALIZED ENGAGEMENT WITH
SURVIVORS THAT WE WILL INCREASE
THE NUMBER REPORT.
I ALSO THINK THAT -- THERE'S A
HUGE AMOUNT OF EDUCATION FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE TEEN DATING
VIOLENCE IS ON A RISE.
AND THERE'S A LOT OF OF ISSUES
THAT ARE GOING ON THAT THAT
WE'RE TRYING. TO TO YOU KNOW GO
LOWER AND LOWER IN THE AGE GROUP --
TO EDUCATE AND TO HELP TRY TO
PREVENT [inaudible]
THIS MORNING.
SO IT WOULD GO FOR THAT I THINK
IT'S REALLY CRITICAL AND YOU
KNOW THE SAD ASIDE FROM THE
DISTANT DISTRICT THAT HASN'T
REALLY CHANGED VERY MUCH.
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WHEN
I FIRST BECAME INVOLVED ABOUT
NOT REPORTING WHAT WE ALSO KNOW
IS THAT ONLY ABOUT 5% OF CASES
THAT ARE REPORTED.
END UP IN A COURT ROOM.
SO WE'VE GOT WORK TO DO IN WITH
MY OWN PROFESSION ABOUT THAT AND
WE'RE WE ARE EMBARKING ON THAT
TO TRY TO EDUCATE PROSECUTORS
ABOUT.
THE PROVABILITY OF CASES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
VICTIMS TO HAVE THEIR JUSTICE.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION CENTER VALLEY WE WOULD
ASKING ABOUT -- THE BUDGET AND
HOW TO HELP OUT -- I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF A LOT OF
INTEREST FROM THE MEMBERS UP ON
THE DíAS THAT WERE HERE EARLIER
AS WELL ONE FIGURE OUT HOW WE
TACKLE THIS PROBLEM.
AND PAGE ONE OF THE **** CENTER
LEYVA YEAH WE JUST PENSION
SENATOR LAND AND HERE YOU ARE.
A SELLER LABOR [inaudible]
BUDGET.
NASA'S ARRIVAL WE'RE JUST --
TALKING ABOUT YOUR LEGISLATION
BUT ALSO -- THE BUDGET **** I
WOULD GO WITH IT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE TEST ALL.
ALL THE KIDS WE'VE HAD TESTIMONY
FOR ME TO THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICES -- ABOUT THAT.
AND BEST PRACTICES MAY BE YOU
KNOW WHY WE GO TO EVIDENCE OR I
KNOW I'VE READ SOME STORIES WERE.
AT KIDS BEEN SITTING IN EVIDENCE
FOR YEARS ALMOST YOU KNOW NINE
TEN YEARS SOMETIMES -- IN
MEANWHILE THERE'S OTHER VICTIMS
DURING THAT TIME AND YOU KNOW
WHAT WE CAN DO TO DO THAT -- I
WOULD DO APPRECIATE FORM OF
JUSTICE TALKING ABOUT SPEAKING
ABOUT AGREEING WITH THE AUDITS.
AND THE NEED TO FOCUS ON THE
OUTCOMES.
RIGHT -- AND SO I WAS JUST
WONDERING FROM DOJ'S POINT OF
VIEW.
WHAT MORE CAN WE DO TO HELP GET
THOSE CASE OUTCOMES YOU HAD
MENTIONED -- YOU KNOW YOU GUYS
SENT OUT A BULLETIN.
OF WHAT YOU EXPECT FROM EACH OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES BUT SIR
ANYTHING MORE THAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT IN TERMS OF DOJ
TRYING TO GET THIS CASE HOW COME
INFORMATION THAT WE NEED OR IS
THIS JUST HAS TO BE A
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE AND THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE AT WELL.
UNTIL THERE'S A LEGISLATIVE
MANDATEIT'S GOING TO BE A
MATTER OF ENFORCEABILITY AND WE
JUST DON'T HAVE -- RIGHT NOW THE
ENFORCEABILITY TO GO OUT AND SAY
YOU HAVE TO FOLLOW A MEMORANDUM
OF UNDERSTANDING.
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
WE AGREE THAT THIS -- MANDATE --
TO HAVE CHOP ENTRY IS CRUCIAL
BECAUSE THAT DOES GIVE -- LAW
ENFORCEMENT SOME GUIDANCE AS TO
WHAT THEY NEED TO BE DOING AND
TAKES THE BURDEN THEY'LL STILL
BE AN OUTRAGE BURDEN FOR US TO
GO OUT THERE AND MAKE SURE THAT
THE DATABASE IS BEING UPDATED --
BUT IT WON'T BE A SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSETHERE WILL BE A MANDATE
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ENTER IT.
AND I THINK THAT'S I THINK
THAT'S ULTIMATELY WHAT WE
DEFINITELY SUPPORT.
GOT IT SIR MANDATING THAT THEIR
REPORTS OF THIS INFORMATION IN
THE DATABASES ARE THEY JUST NOT
DOING IT -- RELATED SPECIFICALLY
TO SEXUAL ASSAULT I WANNA MAKE
THAT CLEAR YEAH.
WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING AT OUTCOME
REPORTING FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT IS
ALREADY MANDATED THAT THEY TRACK
THE KIDS NOW -- IN THE SAFETY
DATABASE -- MEETING WITH A
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS THEY
ACTUALLY PUT THE INFORMATION IN
THERE SO THAT WE CAN HAVE THAT
PERSPECTIVE LOOK AT WHAT'S OUT
THERE -- AND A FEW OTHER DATA
POINTS THAT THAT WILL HOPEFULLY
BE ABLE TO REPORT ON THIS YEAR --
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT ONCE
THE NOTIFICATION HAS BEEN MADE
IF WE'RE IF WE'RE LOOKING AT
THIS IS KIND OF A SPLIT PROCESS.
THE LABORATORIES RUN THE
EVIDENCE GET A DNA PROFILE GET
IT INTO THE SYSTEM AND GET THE
HIT NOTIFICATION OUT AND WE HAVE
A LOT OF HIT NOTIFICATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE THE DATABASE
INCREASED SO MUCH IN SIZE.
WE HAVE THE FOURTH LARGEST
DATABASE IN THE WORLD.
SO IT'S VERY IT'S A VERY LARGE
DATA -- SO AS OUR HIT
NOTIFICATIONS INCREASE WE STOP
AT SENDING OUT THE HIT
NOTIFICATION AND NOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS THE OUTCOMES.
WASN'T INVESTIGATED WAS ITS
PROSECUTED WAS IT A JUDICATA WAS
THERE AN EXONERATION THOSE ARE
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE ASKING --
TO BE TRACKED AND THAT WE WERE
TRYING TO ASK NICELY THROUGH THE
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
PROCESS BUT WE ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
THEIR OWN RESOURCE ISSUES.
BUT AS FAR AS GETTING THAT
INFORMATION AND WE FEEL THAT'S
THE WAY THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET
IT.
YEAH AND I THINK HEARD SEVERAL
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT TESTIMONY
ABOUT THE OUTCOMES WHAT THAT
ACTUALLY MEANS OR TESTING EVERY
KID FOR OTHER CASES -- BUT THE
OUTCOME INFORMATION I THINK ALSO
WILL LET US KNOW BETWEEN EACH
LAW ENFORCEMENT OR PERHAPS A
VERY EVERY COUNTY -- WHY THEY'RE
NOT TESTING THINGS IT WAS IT WAS
CONSENSUAL BUT DOES THAT
ACTUALLY STILL FACTOR INTO
ANOTHER CASE AND I THINK MISS
AMOUNT YOU TALKED ABOUT?
SOME OF THAT -- AS WELL AND I'M
STERN FIGURE FROM THE AGES
PERSPECTIVE HOW DO WE MOVE THAT
ALONG SHORT OF DOING -- A
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE YOU'RE
SAYING THE LEGISLATIVE MANDATE
IS CAN I GET SAYS THERE BUT FOR
DOJ'S.
POINT YOU'RE TRYING.
I GUESS FOR YES -- YEAH AND THE
WHY A OR IF A LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY DID NOT TURN A SEXUAL
ASSAULT EVIDENCE KIT INTO A
LABORATORY IS SOMETHING THAT IS
TRACKED IN THE SAFETY DATABASE.
WHETHER OR NOT IT ACTUALLY WENT
TO A CRIME LAB -- SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO REPORT ON IN THE SAFETY
REPORT TO THIS YEAR -- THE
OUTCOME INFORMATION AS TO WHY IT
WAS INVESTIGATED -- THAT.
MAY OR MAY NOT BE ENTERED AT
THIS POINT YOU KNOW -- THE WISE --
IT'S MOSTLY JUST DID THIS LEAD
TO AN INVESTIGATION DID THIS
LEAD TO A PROSECUTION.
SO WITH THE SAFETY DATABASE CAN
WE ASCERTAIN HOW MANY KIDS HAVE
BEEN SITTING THERE FOR X. AMOUNT
OF YEARS OF SAFE WE WANTED TO
RUN REPORT AND SAY HOW MANY KIDS
HAVE BEEN.
LEFT FOR EIGHT PLUS YEARS IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT THE DATABASE
CAN PROVIDER NOW ONLY FROM
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
FORWARD.
ONLY AS OF LAST YEAR BUT THERE
WAS LEGISLATION IN FUNDING THAT
WAS PASSED LAST YEAR ALSO --
THAT GAVE MONEY TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO GO IN AND DO
THEIR AUDIT.
SO THAT AND I KNOW THAT THEIR
BEEN.
THINK ABOUT NINE OR TEN AGENCIES
IN THE STATE BUT THERE IS MONEY
THAT THE BUT IN THE BUDGET FROM
LAST YEAR JUST TO DO THE OUGHT.
OKAY PERHAPS AS A FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS FOR THE SUBCOMMITTEES.
ALL RIGHT -- WITH THAT LET ME
ASK THERE'S ANY MORE QUESTIONS.
SENATOR LEYVA PLEASE.
PLEASE.
THANK YOU WELL MISTER CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE TODAY
SINCE I DON'T SIT ON THE
COMMITTEE BUT THIS IS JUST
SOMETHING I'M INCREDIBLY
PASSIONATE ABOUT -- WE HAVE A
LOT OF OUR CHAMPIONS HERE TODAY
DO MALLEY THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE ELSA CONNECT FROM THE
JOYFUL HEART FOUNDATION AND THE
TASHA SIMONE.
ON CINCO FROM NATASHA'S JUSTICE
PROJECT WE ALL WORKED VERY HARD
LAST YEAR ON SB OF FOURTEEN
FORTY NINE GOT IT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK AND HE VETOED
THE BILL.
WHICH WAS VERY DISHEARTENING BUT
WE STILL PERSIST BECAUSE IT'S
JUST THAT IMPORTANT AND IN THE
LAW DOES THE CHANGE BECAUSE THE
LAWS PERMISSIVE NOW AND IT SAYS.
THEY SHOULD BE TESTED AND WE SEE
THAT THAT HAS CREATED THIS
BACKLOG AND IF WE CAN CHANGE ONE
WORD TO SHALL BE TESTED.
THEN WE KNOW THAT WE WILL EVER
HAVE A BACKLOG AGAIN SO -- I
THINK ALL OF YOU FOR THE WORK
THAT YOU DO AND FOR ALL THE
STRONG SUPPORTERS AND FOR WHAT
YOU DO.
YOU KNOW IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
WHEN THE GOVERNOR SIGNED SB
EIGHT THIRTEEN ELIMINATING THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS ON RAPE.
INTO LAW THIS IS JUST THE NEXT
LOGICAL STEP AND I JUST DON'T
EVER WANT PEOPLE TO FORGET THAT.
A RAPE VICTIM CANNOT BECOME A
SURVIVOR UNTIL THEIR KID IS
TESTED AND AS YOU HEARD THE
CHAIR SAY THERE ARE SO MANY
PEOPLE THAT.
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN RAPED OR
ASSAULTED IF THAT PERSON HAD
BEEN PUT BEHIND BARS SO THIS IS
JUST THE NEXT LOGICAL STEP AND
WE NEED TO DO THIS SO THANK YOU
ALL FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK AND
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SAY A FEW
WORDS THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE THANK YOU GUYS FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY IN.
I'M SURE WE'LL HAVE ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSIONS AND SUBCOMMITTEES
BUT EVEN AS LEGISLATION MOVES
FORWARD -- WITH THAT LET'S GO TO
MOVE TO OUR OUR NEXT PANELIST
COMMENTS FROM SEXUAL ASSAULT
VICTIMS ADVOCATE GROUPS WE HAVE --
THE DIRECTOR POLICY AND ADVOCACY
FOR THE JOYFUL HEART FOUNDATION.
YEP ALSO CONNECT NATASHA A LINK --
AUTHORED SPOKES PERSON FOR
NATASHA'S JUSTICE PROJECT.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR BEING HERE
AND HOPEFULLY -- YOU'VE BEEN
PAYING ATTENTION TO THE
TESTIMONY AND HOPEFULLY IT'S
HELPFUL.
THANK YOU PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
YOU WANT ME TO GO FIRST.
THE EITHER YEAH OKAY OKAY --
JUST IDENTIFIED IN THE RECORD
ESTAS A GOOD MORNING BUT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE ESTA MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME -- I AM
ALSO CONNECTED THE PULSING
ADVOCACY DIRECTOR FOR THE JOYFUL
HEART FOUNDATION -- I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE OF
UNTESTED RAPE KITS FOR TWENTY
YEARS.
A JOYFUL HEART WAS FOUNDED BY
LAW AND ORDER ACTORS AN ADVOCATE
MARCIA HARGETT TODAY.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND AND TEN WE
MADE ELIMINATING THE RAPE KIT
BACKLOG OUR TOP ADVOCACY
PRIORITY. TO THAT END WE ARE
LEADING A NATIONAL CAMPAIGN TO
PASS LEGISLATION IN EVERY STATE.
THAT ENSURES THAT EVERY KID IS
TESTED IN THE BACKLOG NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN.
LAST YEAR IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
WE PASSED FIFTY BILLS IN THIRTY
TWO STATES AFFECTING A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
SURVIVORS.
SO YOU'VE HEARD IT A LOT TODAY --
DNA EVIDENCE CONTAINED IN RATE
CUTS IS A VERY POWERFUL TOOL FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT. TO SOLVE AND
PREVENT CRIME.
WHEN TESTED IT CAN IDENTIFY
UNKNOWN OFFENDERS THEY CAN LINK
CRIMES TOGETHER OF COURSE THIS
IS HOW WE FIND A SERIAL RAPIST
AND?
IT CAN ALSO EXONERATE THE
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED AND THAT
HAS HAPPENED BY TESTING RIGHT
KIDS.
NEWS WHEN I READ A FEW RAPE KIT
TESTING SUCCESS HEADLINES FROM
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
FROM THIS LAST YEAR.
MEMPHIS MAN CONVICTED IN TWO
THOUSAND RAPE AFTER DNA LINKED
HIM TO ATTACK.
TESTING OF TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
SEXUAL ASSAULT KIT LEADS TO
ORGAN RAPE CONVICTION.
ARREST MADE IN HOC I THINK IT'S
HOPE COUNTY RAPE KIDNAPPING COLD
CASE AFTER REAP CA IS SENT FOR
DNA TESTING.
SIMILAR HEADLINES ARE PUBLISHED
EVERY SINGLE DAY AND I WANT TO
JUST HIGHLIGHT AGAIN THE TRAGIC
NORTH CAROLINA CASE WHERE.
THE MURDER AND RAPE OF A
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD GIRL COULD
HAVE BEEN PREVENTED.
AFRICA A RAPE KIT -- FAULT HAD
BEEN FOLLOW UP FOLLOWED UP ON
CITY SORRY.
AND ALSO JUST TO MENTION I AM
JUST A FOLLOW UP ON WHAT DO
MALLEY SAID THERE HAS BEEN A
RECENT CASE TESTS -- WHERE RICK
IT WAS TESTED AND A STRANGER
RAPE WAS SOLVED BECAUSE AN
ACQUAINTANCE RAPE?
WAS IN THE SYSTEM SO THEY DIDN'T
HAVE A LEAD.
ON THE STRANGER RAPE THE
PERSON'S DNA WAS NOT THE
DATABASE BECAUSE THE TWO CASES
CONNECTED AND THEY COULD GO BACK
TO THE QUEEN'S RAPE FILE AND
THEY GOT A NAME THEY WERE ABLE
TO SOLVE THAT CRIME.
THE DETROIT WHERE THEY'VE TESTED
MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND RAPE KITS
THEY HAVE DISCOVERED MORE THAN
EIGHT HUNDRED SERIAL OFFENDERS
WHO HAVE COMMITTED CRIMES.
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND FORTY
STATES AND WASHINGTON DC LIKE MY
ALL KINDS OF CRIMES AND THEY
COMMIT ALL KINDS OF RAPE AGAINST
PEOPLE THEY KNOWN PEOPLE THEY
DON'T KNOW.
AND CLEVELAND IS IDENTIFIED MORE
THAN EIGHT HUNDRED ZERO MIGHT
PASS AS WELL.
IN ADDITION RESEARCH OUT OF THE
BEGUN CENTER AT CASE WESTERN
UNIVERSITY IN CUYAHOGA COUNTY
FOUND THAT SERIAL RAPISTS ARE.
FAR MORE COMMON THAN WE
PREVIOUSLY KNEW AND THEIR
RECOMMENDATION IS NOW THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT LOOK AT EVERY SINGLE
RATE CASE AS A POSSIBLE SERIAL
CASE.
SO THE VALUE OF TESTING RATE
CUTS IS UNDENIABLE IN THE NEED
FOR REFORM IS ALSO UNDENIABLE.
WE HAVE PLENTY OF EVIDENCE NOW
THAT TESTING EVERYTHING OVER IT
IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO AND THE
THING IS THIS IS A FIXABLE
PROBLEM WE ACTUALLY CAN FIX THIS.
BUT IT NEEDS TO BE LEGISLATED.
SO YOU MAY BE ASKING WHAT DOES
COMPREHENSIVE RATE CAN REFORM
LOOK LIKE WELL CHOICE FOR HER
DOES DEVELOP SIX ESSENTIAL
PILLARS FOR RATE CAN'T REFORM
ONE IS AN ANNUAL STATEWIDE
INVENTORY.
COUNTING ALL UNTESTED KIDS ON A
RECURRING BASIS.
REQUIRING THE SUBMISSION OF ALL
PREVIOUSLY UNTESTED CATS THAT
ARE IDENTIFIED IN THE AUDIT --
AND MAKING SURE THAT THOSE ARE
SENT TO A LAB AND TESTED IN A
TIMELY MANNER -- I WANT TO MAKE
ONE NOTE THAT THAT DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE ANONYMOUS KIDS OR
THE ON REPORTED KIDS WHICH IS A
WHOLE OTHER TOPIC BUT YOU KNOW
CASUALLY -- SURVIVORS THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO HAVE EVIDENCE
COLLECTED AND NOT NECESSARILY
PARTICIPATE IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE PROCESS SO THAT KßT
CAN JUST BE HELD UNTIL THEY
MAYBE MAKE THAT DECISION TO GO
FOR IT SO.
WE DO NOT SUGGEST TESTING THOSE
KIDS WITHOUT SURVIVOR PERMISSION.
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT RAPE KITS
THAT ARE CONNECTED TO A REPORTED
CRIME.
THE MANDATORY TESTING OF NEW
KIDS REQUIRING LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO SUBMIT ALL CATS THAT ARE
CONNECTED TO REPORTED CRIME FOR
TESTING WITH IN A TIMELY MANNER --
WE SUGGEST WITHIN SEVEN DAYS AND
ALSO MAKE SURE THAT.
THERE ARE TIME LINES THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS OF FOR EXAMPLE.
WHEN A KID IS COLLECTED AT?
THE MEDICAL CENTER OR EVEN
SOMETIMES A A RATE TREATMENT
CENTER -- TO MANDATE THAT THOSE
KIDS ACTUALLY GET PICKED UP
BECAUSE SOMETIMES THEY ACT THEY
WILL SIT AT THE HOSPITAL NEVER
BE PICKED UP FROM THE HOSPITAL.
SO IN MANDATE FORTY EIGHT HOURS
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO PICK UP
THE CAT FROMTHE HOSPITAL. SEVEN
DAYS TO SEND IT ON TO A LAB FOR
TESTING AND THEN WE SUGGEST
LAGGED LAB TURN AROUND TIMES FOR
TESTING AS WELL.
TRACKING SYSTEMS TO ENSURE THAT
THE RAPE KITS ARE TRACKED FROM
POINT A TO POINT C. SO THIS
WOULD INCLUDE -- YOU KNOW WHAT
WHOEVER BUYS THE CAT IF IT'S THE
HOSPITAL OR THE STATE LAB YOU
KNOW SUB A BAR CODE ON THAT.
NO WHERE IT STARTS NO WHEN IT
GOES TO THE HOSPITAL KNOW WHEN
IT'S USED AT THE HOSPITAL KNOW
WHEN IT'S PICKED UP FROM THE
HOSPITAL.
AND THE NO ONE IS LOGGED INTO
EVIDENCE.
AT LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THEN ALSO
AT THE LAB AND WHAT HAPPENS
THROUGH THE LAB PROCESS.
THAT IS A WAY TO INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY TRANSPARENCY
ABOUT THREE CAN HANDLING SYSTEM.
AND BUILD IN A WAY FOR SURVIVORS
TO BE ABLE TO LOG INTO THAT
SYSTEM TO CHECK WHERE THE RAPE
KIT IS AT ALL TIMES BECAUSE MANY
OF THEM LEAVE THE HOSPITAL THEY
NEVER EVER HEAR AGAIN.
WHERE THEIR KID IS?
A VICTIMS RIGHTS TO KNOW THE
STATUS OF THEIR CATS -- SING
LEGISLATION ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THAT GRANTS VICTIMS THE RIGHT TO
KNOW WHERE THEIR KID AS IN MOST
STATES THEY DO NOT ACTUALLY HAVE
THAT RIGHT NOW AND MANY OF THEM
AGAIN.
NEVER FIND OUT WHERE THEIR KID
IS AND THEN OF COURSE FUNDING
FOR ALL OF THESE REFORMS -- IT
DOES COST MONEY TO TEST RATE
CUTS AND SO IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE STATE. TO STEP UP AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE SUPPORTING
THESE EFFORTS ARE APPROPRIATIONS.
SO TODAY TWENTY THREE STATES
HAVE MANDATED THE COLLECTION OR
THE TESTING OF NEWLY COLLECTED
RATE CUTS. TEN STATES REQUIRE
THE TESTING OF BOTH BACKLOG AND
NEWLY COLLECTED KIDS THE STATE'S
OUR COLORADO GEORGIA HAWAII
ILLINOIS KENTUCKY MASSACHUSETTS
NEW YORK OHIO PENNSYLVANIA AND
TEXAS.
HOW YA KENTUCKY MASSACHUSETTS
NEW YORK AND TAXES ALL HAVE
ENACTED FULL REFORM?
AND MASSACHUSETTS IN KENTUCKY
JUST IN THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS.
MICHIGAN OF SORRY COLORADO
ILLINOIS MICHIGAN NEVADA OHIO
UTAH AND WASHINGTON STATE ARE
ALSO CLOSE TO FULL REFORM.
THE CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO JOIN
THIS GROWING LIST OF STATES THAT
ARE REFORMING THE WAY THAT
THEY'RE HANDLING RIGHT KIDS.
HERE'S A SNAPSHOT OF WHERE
CALIFORNIA STANDS ON REFORM AND
WE'VE BEEN HERE A LONG TIME SO I
HAVE.
A LOT IN MY WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THAT YOU CAN LOOK AT I JUST
WANNA LET YOU KNOW THAT SO FAR
CALIFORNIA HAS PASSED FOUR OF
OUR SIX PILLARS.
THAT IS THE INVENTORY THAT WE WE
PASSED LAST YEAR WITH A SOME IN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU -- TO
MANDATE A ONE TIME AUDIT OF
UNTESTED KIDS YOU HEARD A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT IN THE PREVIOUS
PANEL WE DON'T REALLY HAVE A
SENSE RIGHT NOW HOW THAT STUFF'S
GOING BUT IT IS A MANDATE -- AND
THE RESULTS ARE DUE IN JULY OF
TWENTY NINETEEN SO THAT'S A ONE
TIME ON IT WE LIKE TO SEE THAT
RECURRING -- THERE'S TRACKING OF
COURSE YOU HEARD ABOUT THAT
TODAY THROUGH THE CAL DOJ
TRACKING SYSTEM THERE ARE SOME
HOLES IN THAT -- DID YOU HAVE
VICTIMS RATES CALIFORNIA WAS ONE
OF THE FIRST STATES TO PASS A
VICTIM'S RIGHT TO KNOW THE
STATUS OF THEIR CAT AND TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE AND THEN
FUNDING OF COURSE YOU HEARD
ABOUT SOME OF THE FUNDING THAT
WAS PUT INTO -- THE BUDGET LAST
YEAR.
SO THE ROAD AHEAD OF HER HEAD
COUNT FOR CALIFORNIA -- YOU KNOW
WE WE WERE PART OF THE THE PUSH
LAST YEAR AGAIN WITH NATASHA --
AND DO MALATE TO GET.
A MANDATORY TESTING OF RICH KIDS
IN CALIFORNIA AND AS YOU HEARD
THE GOVERNOR VETOED THAT BILL.
I'M MORE WORKING ON THAT NOW
WOULD LIKE TO PUT CALIFORNIA ON
OUR MAP.
A FULL REFORM ME LIKE THEM LIKE
TO JOIN.
THE STATE'S LIKE AWAY KENTUCKY
AND TEXAS -- AND BE IN THE FIRST
TEN STATES TO DO SO I THINK IT'S
A IS -- SOMETHING THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN DO AND CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE A LEADER IN THIS AREA.
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS FOR CHANGE
IN CALIFORNIA ARE TOO FIRST AND
FOREMOST PASSED SENATE BILL --
TWENTY TWO THIS SESSION A
MANDATE THAT TESTING OF ALL CATS --
I DO WANT TO MENTION I I DO
THINK -- AND I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHERE THIS FITS BUT
THERE ARE COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WHO ARE SENDING.
KIDS DIRECTLY FROM THE
COLLECTION POINT TO THE LAB AND
SKIPPING LAW ENFORCEMENT
ALTOGETHER I THINK THAT THAT IS
A FABULOUS IDEA -- WE ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO MANDATE -- PARTICIPATION
IN TO THE CODIS -- HEAD OUT COME
[inaudible]
PROJECT PLATFORM -- I THINK THAT
THAT WOULD MEAN A FOLLOWING
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THESE KIDS
ON THIS TESTING SOUP IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTANDING WHAT
WE'RE DOING WITH OUR KIDS IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO IN -- TWENTY SEVENTEEN JOYFUL
HEARTS A PROJECT CALLED THE
ACCOUNTABILITY PROJECT ISSUED
FREEDOM OF INFORMATION REQUESTS
ARE OPEN RECORDS REQUEST. TO
EIGHT JURISDICTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA AND FOUND THAT SIX
OUT OF EIGHT OR 75%.
ARE EITHER NOT FOLLOWING THE
ENCOURAGEMENT OF THE LAW AS IT
STANDS NOW WHICH BASICALLY
SUGGESTS SENDING RIGHT KITS FOR
TESTING -- OR THEY HAVE NO WAY
OF KNOWING HOW MANY RAPISTS ARE
RECEIVING AND WHERE THEY ARE AND
WHETHER THEY'VE BEEN SENT TO A
LAB FOR TESTING.
SO RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA
DESPITE ALL THE PROOF THAT
TESTING RIGHT KIDS.
IS THE BEST PRACTICE WHETHER OR
NOT EVERY KID GETS TESTED A PINT
DEPENDS ON THE SURVIVORS OF CODE.
AND THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE.
SO AS SOON AS A STATEWIDE
INVENTORY IS DONE THEN THE STATE
MUST MOVE QUICKLY TO MANDATE
TESTING OF ALL THE KIDS THAT ARE
FOUND IN THE INVENTORY ALL THOSE
KIDS THAT ARE CONNECTED TO A
REPORTED CRIME.
AND THEN IN ADDITION TO OUR
STATE APPROPRIATIONS FOR TESTING
THOSE KIDS THERE ARE FERTILE
GROUND SUCH AS A SEXUAL ASSAULT
KIT INITIATIVE GRANT PROGRAMMER
SAKE. TO SUPPORT THE TESTING OF
KIDS INVESTIGATE THE CASES THAT
COME OUT OF THAT PROSECUTING
THOSE CASES AND RE ENGAGING
SURVIVORS AND THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE PROCESS AS A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE GRANT PROGRAM -- I
SPOKE JUST A MINUTE AGO ABOUT
THE ANNUAL INVENTORY -- THAT
REQUIRES A LONG FOR CEMENT.
AGENCY IS -- TO AND OTHER
FACILITIES TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION LIKE TO SEE THAT BI
ANNUAL.
THE WRITTEN INVENTORY THAT'S
REQUIRED UNDER AB FORTY ONE
THROUGH THE CAL DOJ SYSTEM ONLY
INCLUDES INFORMATIONS ABOUT GETS
A LAW ENFORCEMENT ENTER INTO THE
PROCESS INTO THE SYSTEM.
SO THERE'S A WHOLE THERE AND
THAT IT'S NOT INCLUDING KIDS
THAT ARE -- OUR MEDICAL
FACILITIES OR HOSPITALS OR OTHER
CENTERS THAT NEVER MAKE IT TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT SO AS SUCH THE
INVENTORY.
ONLY REALLY GIVES THAT INVENTORY
ONLY REALLY GIVES A PARTIAL
SNAPSHOT OF GREAT CAN HANDLING
IN THE STATE.
ALSO -- THE RATE TO SAFETY
SYSTEM -- IT SHOULD PROVIDE A
WAY FOR SURVIVORS TO LOG IN TO
THE SYSTEM ANONYMOUSLY AND LOOK
FOR THEIR KID AND TO SEE WHERE
THEIR CAT IS -- SO WE WE LIKE TO
SEE THAT ONLINE ANONYMOUS PORTAL
FOR SURVIVORS -- TO TO CHECK ON
WHETHER CAT AS AND THAT HELPS
ALSO OPERATIONALIZE THE
SURVIVORS RIGHT TO KNOW THE
STATUS OF THEIR CAT.
SO -- WE'VE ALSO HEARD ANECDOTES
ACROSS THE STATE HAT SURVIVORS
ARE NOT OFTEN ABLE TO GET
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR KID IT
IS THE STATE LAW.
SO WE RECOMMEND THAT THIS
COMMITTEE IN COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATE HOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
OPPRESSORS OFFICES ARE ENSURING
THAT SURVIVORS HAVE ACCESS TO
THIS INFORMATION.
AND OF COURSE THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO APPROPRIATE.
SUFFICIENT FUNDING TO CARRY OUT
COMPREHENSIVE REFORM
MASSACHUSETTS JUST PAST EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS.
A FEW DAYS AGO AND THEIR BUDGET.
NOW TEXAS ELEVEN NINE IT'S A
HUGE STATE -- TO SO IN CLOSING --
WE OFFER OUR RESOURCES OUR
EXPERTISE AND SUPPORT FROM THE
JOYFUL HEART FOUNDATION HELPS
CALIFORNIA GET TO FULL REFORM.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE DAY
WHEN EVERY BACKLOG CREATE GREAT
KID IS TESTED.
AND THE NO MATTER THERE'S A CODE
SURVIVORS.
NEWLY COLLECTED CUTS ARE TESTED
EXPEDITIOUSLY AND THAT'S WHEN I
SAY THE STAKES ARE ARE TOO HIGH
YOU'VE HEARD IT HERE TODAY -- TO
STRIVE FOR ANYTHING ELSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU THINK
REGIS MONEY WILL MOVE TO
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY ON
QUESTIONS.
PLEASE SO I GO.
THANK YOU -- I I FIRST WANT TO
START OF COURSE I'M A SURVIVOR
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT I AM A
SURVIVOR OF OF THE BACKLOG --
AND I I JUST REALLY WANT TO LET
YOU KNOW HOW ABSOLUTELY HUMBLED
I AM TO BE HERE -- TO SHARE MY
STORY.
THERE'S JUST NO WORDS -- AND AND
JUST TO SEE THE CHAMPIONS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT I'VE BEEN
FIGHTING FOR SO LONG -- FOR RAPE
KIT REFORM IT'S JUST INSPIRING
AND AND AND JUST.
JUST SO YOU KNOW THEIR SURVIVORS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT LOOK TO
SOME OF THE CHAMPIONS HERE IN.
CALIFORNIA THE FIGHTING SO HARD
AND AND WE JUST KNOW AND ADORE
THEM.
ALL SO I'M AND IT'S REALLY A
HUMBLING EXPERIENCE TO BE HERE.
ON I WAS -- I WAS RAPED AND
ROBBED AT GUNPOINT BY AN UNKNOWN
ASSAILANT -- TO SAY THAT IT WAS
LIFE CHANGING AS IS A GREAT
UNDERSTATEMENT -- AND THEN I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO SAY IT
NOT ONLY CHANGE MY LIFE BUT THE
LIFE OF PEOPLE IN MY FAMILY MY
MOTHER IN PARTICULAR.
MY FRIENDS I MEAN THIS WAS A
CRIME THAT WAS COMMITTED ON ME
BUT JUST AFFECTED SO MANY -- OF
COURSE AFTER I WAS ASSAULTED --
MY FIRST INSTINCT OF COURSE WAS
TO TAKE A SHOWER BECAUSE YOU YOU
JUST YOU KNOW WANT TO FORGET
EVERYTHING YOU WANT TO JUST
ERASE.
EVERY HORRIBLE THING THAT'S JUST
HAPPEN TO YOU -- BUT THEN YOU
HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT YOUR BODY
HAS BECOME A CRIME SCENE -- AND
SO I I DID DO A RAPE KIT TESTS
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING THE
ASSAULT.
THE LAST THING I WANTED TO DO
CERTAINLY HAPPY SOMETHING I DID
NOW -- YOU KNOW AFTER AN ASSAULT
TO GO THROUGH THAT PROCESS OF
HAVING A RAPE KITS ON YOU ARE
POKED AND PRODDED.
AT A MOMENT IN YOUR LIFE.
WHERE YOU JUST DON'T WANT
ANYTHING MORE TO DO WITH WHAT
JUST HAPPENED HE WON A MAYBE YOU
KNOW IN MY IN MY CASE I WANTED
TO JUST CRAWL INTO A BALL AND
FORGET ANYTHING IT JUST HAPPENED?
SO ONCE AGAIN YEARS SPLAYED OUT
YOUR ASK QUESTIONS YOU'RE ASKED
TO RECALL THINGS YOU YOU DON'T
WANT TO TALK ABOUT -- BUT I
RECOGNIZE IN THAT MOMENT THAT A
RAPE KIT WAS SO NECESSARY
BECAUSE IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
ME TO FIND.
THIS PERSON THAT HAD DONE THAT
AWFUL THING TO ME AND THAT AWFUL
THING TO MY BODY.
I HAD NO IDEA AT THE TIME THAT
MY RAPE KIT WOULD SIT ON A SHELF
FOR NINE AND A HALF YEARS
COLLECTING DUST.
NO IDEA -- IN MY CASE I HAD NO
IDEA MY RAPE KIT HAD NOT BEEN
TESTED I WOULDN'T IT WOULDN'T
EVEN DAWN ON ME THAT IT WASN'T.
BECAUSE I COULD IMAGINE HAVING
BEEN PUT THROUGH THAT PROCESS
FOR NOTHING -- SO THOSE YEARS OF
THOSE NINE AND A HALF YEARS
WHERE'D HEARD NOTHING.
I BEGAN BLAMING MYSELF FOR NOT
HAVING PUT THAT PERPETRATED
BEHIND BARS.
THERE WAS NO DOUBT IN MY MIND HE
HEARD OTHERS I DON'T THINK IT
TAKES -- A PSYCHOLOGIST TO SAY
OKAY SOMEONE WHO PUTS A GUN TO
SOMEONE'S HEAD.
AND RAPES THEM IS GOING SUDDENLY
BECOME A PILLAR OF STAFF SOCIETY
HAD IF THEY'RE NOT KIND OF
CAUGHT IN AND SO ON SO I KNEW HE
WAS OUT THERE HARMING OTHERS.
AND THE ENTIRE TIME I REALLY
TOOK THE ONUS OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF HAVING SUCH A
DANGEROUS PERSON.
ON MYSELF I BLAME MYSELF PERHAPS
THEY DIDN'T.
ARTICULATE LAW ENFORCEMENT
APPROPRIATELY AND SO I CAN I
CARRY THAT FOR A LOT OF YEARS
AND TELL MY MY CAT WAS TESTED --
FINALLY.
AND ALTHOUGH IT TOOK MANY YEARS
FOR ONCE THE KIT WAS TESTED
THERE WAS INITIALLY NO MATCHING
PROFILING COATIS.
SO IT WASN'T UNTIL -- IS SEVEN
YEARS LATER THAT I MATCH WAS
MADE IN CODE S. AND THE MAN THAT
RATE ME WAS APPREHENDED -- BUT
NOT AFTER HE MADE A COMMITTED
CRIMES IN EIGHT DIFFERENT STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND THE MAN THAT RATE ME WASN'T
A SPECIALIST HE DIDN'T STICK TO
SEXUAL ASSAULTS I'M HE COMMITTED
A VARIETY OF CRIMES HE WAS A
BURDEN ON TAXPAYERS HE WAS A
BURDEN ON LAW ENFORCEMENT HE WAS
A VERY DANGEROUS INDIVIDUAL.
THAT WAS OUT ON THE STREET --
THANKFULLY.
AND THIS IS A RARITY.
I I WAS ABLE TO SEE MY DAY IN
COURT AND I DID I WAS ABLE TO
TESTIFY.
I WAS ABLE TO FACE THE MAN THAT
ASSAULTED ME IN A COURT ROOM.
AND I KNOW THAT I'M AND I'M ONLY
AND I RECOGNIZE HOW.
HOW IMPORTANT IS TO REALLY SPEAK
OUT AND SAY THAT THIS IS NOT
LIKE PAR FOR THE COURSE MY CASE
ISN'T?
HOW IT WORKS IT'S JUST AN
EXAMPLE OF?
IT WORKING WHILE -- SO AFTER I
TESTIFIED.
ON THE TORONTO SUN MAN THAT RATE
MEAN WAS PUT BEHIND BARS TO
TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN WHICH IS A
GREAT TRIUMPH AND CERTAINLY A
TRIUMPH.
THAT IT DIDN'T COME BECAUSE OF
ME BECAME BECAUSE THE
PROSECUTORS.
STRUCK WITH EVERYTHING LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN MY CASE STUCK
WITH EVERYTHING.
AND IT WAS JUST THIS AMAZING
TEAM THAT WORK TOGETHER FOR THE
BEST INTERESTS OF NOT ONLY ME IN
FINDING JUSTICE BUT FOR THE BEST
INTERESTS OF SURVIVORS MOVING
FORWARD AND AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AND AND FOR ALSO PUBLIC SAFETY.
SO.
YOU KNOW MY STORY HAD IT HAD AN
ENDING AND I HAVE -- I HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HAVE CLOSURE ON MY
CASE AND I KNOW THAT'S NOT THE
CASE AND I THINK WHAT ONE OF THE
REASONS I I TALK ABOUT SOMETHING
IT'S SO DIFFICULT TO TALK ABOUT.
IS I I WANT TO ENSURE THAT I'M
NOT AN ANOMALY AND THAT OTHER
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE THE JUSTICE.
THAT I WAS REALLY FORTUNATE TO
HAVE AND ALSO WE USE MY CASES AN
EXPERIENCE FOR LEARNING AND A
WAY TO KIND OF ENSURE THAT WE
ARE USING BEST PRACTICES WE'RE
MAKING SURE KIDS ARE TESTED.
HIS IT'S IT'S GREAT THAT YOU CAN
GATHER DATA AND WE SEE THE DATE
AND IT'S REALLY OBVIOUS THAT WE
SHOULD BE TESTING RAPE KITS BUT
YOU'RE PUTTING SURVIVORS.
IN PART OF THIS PROCESS I THINK
IT'S JUST SO NECESSARY BECAUSE I
THINK SOMETIMES WE HAVE A
TENDENCY TO GET LOST IN THE DATA.
AND FORGET THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
ATTACHED TO THESE RAPE KITS THAT.
WHOSE LIVES OF HAVE CHANGED
FOREVER -- AND IT'S ALSO REALLY
IMPORTANT BIG I THINK IN MY CASE
BECAUSE I WAS ABLE TO RECEIVE
CLOSURE AND I WAS TREATED WITH
SUCH DIGNITY AND RESPECT -- I
WAS KIND OF IN POWER TO BE ABLE
TO COME OUT AN ADVOCATE AND
BECOME AN ADVOCATE AND TALK
ABOUT -- RAPE KIT REFORM AND AN
AND I'M JUST SO INCREDIBLY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT -- I YOU KNOW
THIS IS IT'S INTERESTING THIS IS
THE EIGHTH TIME I'VE COME TO
THIS AMAZING STATE HOUSE WHICH I
THINK IS JUST ABSOLUTELY.
BREATHTAKING AND IT'S ALWAYS
JUST.
SUCH ON IT I'M JUST ALWAYS I AM
IN AWE OF THIS BUILDING AND ALSO
THE PEOPLE THAT.
ARE IN IT -- SENATOR LEYVA
WORKING EXTREMELY HARD ON THIS
LEGISLATION.
THAT I THINK IS SO IMPORTANT.
AND AND I THINK.
CALIFORNIA AS A WHOLE HAS ALL
THESE SUPER HEROES AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT AND NECESSARY TO
LISTEN.
TO THEIR EXAMPLES DA O'MALLEY
AND WHAT SHE DONE AND ALAMEDA
COUNTY IS AMAZING NOT NOT JUST
FOR CALIFORNIA BUT THE ENTIRE
NATION -- AND I THINK THAT
THERE'S JUST THESE AMAZING
PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING GREAT
THINGS IN CALIFORNIA AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO OF BILL DISLIKE
COHESIVE UNIT AND CREATE
LEGISLATION.
SO THAT EVERYTHING IS CONSISTENT
AND THAT SURVIVORS AND IN THE
STATE RECEIVE JUSTICE -- AND
THAT EVERYBODY KIND OF
RECOGNIZES THAT IT'S OKAY TO
COME FORWARD AND SAVE BEEN
ASSAULTED BECAUSE EVERYBODY IS
WORKING. FOR YOUR BEST INTERESTS
I THINK YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT.
RAPE BEING SO UNDERREPORTED IN
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY AS OTHER
SURVIVORS OF TOLD ME AS THAT
THEY JUST DON'T TRUST THAT
ANYTHING MORE IS GOING TO HAPPEN
IN THAT CASE.
I MEAN CERTAINLY A LOT OF IT
COMES FROM THE SHAME AND THE ME
TOO MOVEMENT HAS CERTAINLY WORK
TO EMPOWER SURVIVORS SO THEY CAN.
SHARE THEIR STORIES MORE BUT A
LOT OF TIME SURVIVORS JUST DON'T
FEEL LIKE ANYTHING'S GOING TO BE
DONE.
AND THAT'S REALLY HEARTBREAKING
IT'S IT AND IT'S REALLY.
I THINK CITIZENS SHOULD ALSO BE
OUTRAGE THAT THAT'S THE CASE
BECAUSE AGAIN WHEN WE LOOK AT
INDIVIDUALS WHO.
COMMIT THESE KIND OF CRIMES THEY
DON'T JUST STICK TO RATE THE
CONTINUED EIGHT THE ESCALATE I
MEAN THESE ARE THINGS THAT ARE --
ALL PRETTY MUC COMMON SENSE AND
AND I CAN SPEAK VERY
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE THE MAN
THAT RATE ME OPERATED IN THAT
FASHION [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
I REMAIN.
COMPLETELY COMMITTED -- AS I
HAVE BEEN FOR MANY YEARS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO DO ANYTHING TO
UTILIZE MY STORY TO TO SHARE
ANYTHING I CAN -- TO ENSURE THAT.
CALIFORNIA BECOMES A STATE THAT
LEADS THE NATION IN TERMS OF
LEGISLATION I THINK IT'S SO
IMPORTANT AND AND I THINK IT'S A
YOUNG ONCE ONCE LEGISLATION IS
TO SEE IT KIND OF HAVE THIS
RIPPLE EFFECT AROUND THE COUNTRY --
AND HAVE OTHER STATES YOU KNOW
TAKE ON SIMILAR THINGS.
SO I AM HERE FOR ANYTHING YOU
NEED AGAIN.
COMPLETELY HUMBLE THAT I CAN
SHARE MY STORY AND CERTAINLY
GRATEFUL I'M HERE TODAY TO BE
ABLE. TO TO TALK ABOUT IT -- AND
I I THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN FOR
THE THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THE COURAGE AND STRENGTH
TO CONTINUE TO TELL YOUR STORY
LIKE YOU SAID I BELIEVE I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT
THERE TO HAVE DIFFICULTY DOING
THAT.
SO PRO APOLOGY FOR FOR DOING
THAT BECAUSE IT'S WHAT'S HELPING
CREATE THE CHANGE THAT WE NEED
TO SEE EVERYWHERE.
AND SO ON THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE I DO WHAT I THINK -- SIR
MORLOCK SIR WIENER FOR JOINING
US AS WELL THANK YOU SO MAY I
JUST ASK A GENERAL QUESTION AND
YOU KNOW WE'VE BOTH OF YOUR
TESTIMONIES TOUCHED UPON IT --
BUT ADDITIONALLY YOU FIRST BEGIN
BY SAYING YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA'S
BUT FOUR OF THE SIX PILLARS OF
WERE MISSING THE OTHER.
TWO AND I WAS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THOSE TWO WERE BECAUSE
ONE SOUNDED LIKE TRACKING AND
THEN THE OTHER ONE WAS AND GETS
TO AND PUT INTO THE THE LONG FOR
IT ONLY LAW ENFORCEMENT GETS AND
PUT INTO -- THE DATABASE I
BELIEVE YOU SAID WELL RAPE
CENTERS AND HOSPITALS TO NOT.
SORE THAT WATER THE TWO PILLARS
WERE STILL MISSING IN CALIFORNIA
SO WE COULD.
HAVE THIS FULL REFORM LIKE THE
OTHER STATES DO RIGHT -- SO IT'S
MANDATE IN THE TESTING OF NEWLY
COLLECTED KITS WHICH SB TWENTY
TWO WILL DO.
MANDATING THAT TESTING OF ALL
THE PREVIOUSLY UNTESTED AN
UNSYMPATHETIC KIDS THAT WILL BE
IDENTIFIED -- THROUGH THE STATE
WIDE AUDIT -- AND THEN THERE ARE
YOU KNOW OTHER LITTLE. TWO WEEKS --
TO THE TRACKING SYSTEM I THINK
THAT -- ARE IMPORTANT
[inaudible]
GOT IT.
OKAY I THINK WE JUST TRY TO FIND
WAYS TO BE HELPFUL.
AND SO IT SEEMS LIKE WE'VE BEEN
WE'VE HAD LEGISLATION THAT WE'VE
DONE IN THE PAST WE'VE HAD --
WE'VE UP PUTS MONEY IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET WERE LOOKING TO
PUT MONEY IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
AGAIN I THINK CENTER BALLOT
TALKED ABOUT THAT AND MISS
WEBBER AS WELL.
I MEAN IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE WE
SHOULD BE DOING HIMCALIFORNIA
ASIDE FROM WHAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON TOGETHER. TO TO KIND
OF MOVE THIS ALONG OR ANYTHING
THAT YOU REALIZE IN THE
TESTIMONY MAYBE WITH PREVIOUS
PANEL THAT.
THAT WE SHOULD FOLLOW UP ON BUT
I ACT I THINK THAT THE OUTCOME
INFORMATION IS REALLY IMPORTANT
AND WE BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT YOU
HAVE TO MANDATE.
THESE KINDS OF PARTICIPATION OF
PARTICIPATION.
SORRY OF YOU KNOW IT REALLY
HASN'T HASN'T.
BEEN WORKING -- IN TERMS OF IF
YOU LOOK AT THE THE LAW THAT'S
ON THE BOOKS NOW THAT SAYS THAT
ONE PERSON SHOULD SEND.
KIDS FOR TESTING -- THAT JUST
HASN'T WORKED -- AS WELL
INTENTIONED AT THE TIME BUT IT'S
PRETTY CLEAR WE HAVE TO MANDATE
THAT I DO THINK -- THAT
MANDATING PARTICIPATION IN SOME
KIND OF OUTCOME.
YOU KNOW PROJECT IN MAKING SURE
THAT EVERY BIT Là PERSON HAS TO
ENTER THE INFORMATION AND
PROSECUTORS HAVE GENTRAN
INFORMATION TO THAT.
OTHERWISE YOU'RE JUST GONNA GET
A PATCHWORK QUILT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND YOU REALLY WON'T GET
THAT KIND OF SOLID.
DATA THAT YOU THAT YOU WANT.
AND I THINK THAT'S OF THOSE
DEFINITELY IDENTIFIED IN THE
AUDIT SENDS YOU KNOW AS PLEASED
TO HEAR PART OF JUST TO SAY THAT
SOMETHING THAT THEY THINK WE
SHOULD MOVE TOWARDS AS WELL YEAH
I MEAN THAT ACTUALLY WOULD BE --
EVER KIND OF A FIRST OF
CALIFORNIA DID THAT -- THERE ARE
OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT ARE DOING
SIMILAR KIND OF OUTCOME -- HAVE
SORT OF SIMILAR OUTCOME --
PROCESS -- PLATFORMS FOR LACK OF
A BETTER WORD -- BUT IN TERMS OF
MANDATING SOMETHING LIKE THAT I
MEAN THAT WOULD BE PRETTY --
GROUND BREAKING.
YEAH NOW AND YEAH I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT I KNOW IN THE
PREVIOUS PANEL WE HEARD ABOUT --
WHETHER IT'S AN IMPLICIT BIAS OR
BABY WAS.
THEY FOUND THAT IT WAS
CONSENSUAL SO THEY DECIDED NOT.
TO SEND THE RAPE KIT TO THE TO
BE TESTED BUT KNOWING THAT
ACTUALLY HAS.
A LOT OF OTHER IMPLICATIONS AS
WELL RIGHT MORE DNA YOU HAVE
INTO.
INTO THE DATABASE AND YOU CAN
ACTUALLY SEE IF THERE'S A
PATTERN WITH THE SURNAME VISUAL
AND AND HOW THAT -- PLAYS OUT
WITH.
OTHER -- POTENTIAL VICTIMS AS
WELL.
YEAH RIGHT RIGHT YEAH WE HAVE A
A LOT OF INFORMATION IN OUR
WRITTEN TESTIMONY ABOUT YOU KNOW
WHY THE BACK LIKE OCCURS WHITE
KIDS AREN'T SOME FOR TESTING --
ANYTHING TO THAT CAN YOU EXPAND
A LITTLE BIT ON BECAUSE YOU HAD
TALKED ABOUT -- THE VICTIMS --
BEING ABLE TO LOG IN AND SEE THE
STATUS OF THEIR KIDS AS
SOMETHING THAT'S DONE IN OTHER
STATES.
YEAH QUITE A FEW QUITE A FEW
STATES HAVE DONE THIS -- LET'S
SAY MICHIGAN WASHINGTON STATE --
ARIZONA.
IN TERMS SOME OF THE OTHER ONES
ON NEVADA STANDING UP A SYSTEM
NOW -- I CAN GET YOU A FULL LIST
OF THAT BUT THAT IS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS REALLY IS BUILT INTO
MOST TRACKING SYSTEMS THAT ARE
BEING STOOD UP NOW.
IS THAT ANONYMOUS WAY FOR
VICTIMS TO LOG IN THROUGH A
PORTAL AND AND SEE WHETHER
CANDACE AND YOU DON'T SEE THAT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY.
NOT THAT I MEAN I COULD BE I
COULD BE WRONG I JUST DON'T THAT
I HAVEN'T BEEN.
AWARE THAT IT EXISTS.
ALL RIGHT ONE OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE IS STILL IN THE ROOM
FOR A BABY THE AUDITOR I CAN
MAYBE I CAN ASK THE STATE
AUDITOR'S A SOMETHING THAT YOU
GUYS LOOKED AT OR NOW
[inaudible]
OKAY.
HI WELL THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU
ON HER YEAH YEAH I THINK I THINK
OF VICTIMS PORTAL IN IN TERMS OF
THAT TRACKING IS IS.
OFFICIAL FOR SO MANY ARE A
VARIETY OF REASONS BUT YES
CERTAINLY I THINK THAT I'VE
HEARD THE SAME THING THAT
CALIFORNIA HASN'T QUITE GOTTEN
TO THAT POINT YET BUT AND I JUST
MENTION THAT TO TASHA WAS PART
OF SOME RESEARCH TREATED AT
JOYFUL HEART FOUNDATION ABOUT
VICTIM NOTIFICATION IN.
THESE CASES THESE VERY OLD CASES
WHERE YOU GET THEM NEW
INFORMATION INDICATES CAM NEWLY
ACTIVATED AFTER YOU KNOW DECADE
SOMETIMES.
HOW DO YOU GO TELL SURVIVORS?
YOU KNOW WE HAVE NO INFORMATION
IN YOUR CASE AFTER THE SYSTEM
FAILED THEM SO POORLY -- AND SO
WE'VE DONE RESEARCH ON THAT AND
SURVIVORS TOLD US THAT.
THAT HAVING INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR CASE AND THEIR KID IS SO
IMPORTANT TO THEIR HEALING IS
VERY CENTRAL TO THEIR HEALING
THEY REALLY STRONGLY FEEL THAT
THAT INFORMATION BELONGS TO THEM
AND THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO IT.
ABSOLUTELY AND THAT ACTUALLY NOT
THE NOT HAVING ACCESS TO IT
ACTUALLY DOES NOT HARM.
I THINK THAT'S WHY WE'RE ALL
WORKING SO HARD AND DILIGENTLY
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
AND JUSTICE IS MET FOR EVERYONE
AND I KNOW CALIFORNIA FIRST WERE.
TRYING TO TACKLE.
HOW BIG OF A BACKLOG WE HAD HOW
MANY KIDS HAVE BEEN SITTING?
YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY FOR NOT NINE
YEARS ARE NINE AND A HALF YEARS --
BECAUSE I THINK MOST PEOPLE ARE
UNDERTHE ASSUMPTION WHY DID THE
KID AND IT SHOULD BE TESTED AND
WHY WOULDN'T IT BE TESTED.
AND SO -- YOU KNOW PLEASE BE
LOOKING FOR TO THE AUDIT REPORT
FOR LATER THIS YEAR AS WELL AS
SEE WHAT THAT ACTUALLY LOOKS
LIKE AT LOOK THE LOCAL LAW.
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT TH STATE --
I THINK WE HAVE SOME GOOD
EXAMPLES OF WHAT ALAMEDA IS
DEFINITELY DOING.
AND WHAT -- TA O'MALLEY.
IS DOING THEIR MISTER CARTER
TALKED ABOUT -- IN THE PREVIOUS
PANEL AS WELL SO JUST OTHER JEFF
CHAMPIONS HERE THAT WANT TO HELP
CONTINUE TO HELP WE WANT TO BE --
WE WANT TO HIT ALL SIX OF THOSE
PILLARS.
AND THEY WERE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IF
THERE'S JUST A QUESTIONS FROM
THE DíAS.
HEARING SEEING THEN -- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU AND WITH
THAT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND CONCLUDE --
THIS JOINT HEARING OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE THE
ASSEMBLY.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE SENATE
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE
A CORRECTIONS PUBLIC SAFETY IN
THE JUDICIARY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH [inaudible]
YEAH.
THE STRESS PHONE WHEN
[inaudible]
MONEY ON AND MAYBE